Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the restishistory.com and join the club. That is, the rest is history.com. woods, and last night being chased by gunboats, till I was forced to return wet, cold and starving, with every man's hand against me. I am here, in despair. And why? For doing what Brutus was honoured for. What made William tell a hero? And yet I, for striking down a greater tyrant than they ever knew,
感谢您收听《一切皆历史》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、提前解锁系列内容，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 the restishistory.com 加入俱乐部。也就是 the rest is history.com。森林，昨晚还遭到炮艇的追逐，直到我被迫在湿冷饥饿中返回，所有人都与我为敌。我在这里，陷入绝望。为什么？因为做了布鲁图斯受人尊敬的事。是什么让威廉成为英雄？然而我，却在击倒一个比他们所知更伟大的暴君之后，
and looked upon as a common cutthroat. My action was purer than either of theirs. One hoped to be great himself. The other had not only his countries, but his own wrongs to avenge. I hoped for no gains. I knew no private wrong. I struck for my country. And that alone.
却被看作是一个普通的拦路杀手。我的行动比他们任何人的都要纯粹。一个人希望自己伟大。另一个人不仅要报复国家，还要报复他自己受到的冤屈。我不求任何利益。我不知私怨。我为国出击。仅此而已。
A country groaned beneath this tyranny and prayed for this end. And yet now behold, the cold hand they extend to me. I do not repent the blow I struck. I may before my God. So that was John Wilkes Booth, great Shakespearean actor. Dominant, you described him in the previous episode as being very much the Brian Blessed school of acting. And he wrote that in his journal on the 21st of April 1865 while he was on the run for the murder of Abraham Lincoln, the 16th president of the United States. And the murder of Lincoln often framed as being one of the most consequential crimes in American history.
一个国家在这种暴政下呻吟，并祈祷着这个结局。然而现在看啊，他们向我伸出的冰冷的手。我不后悔我挥下的那一拳。在我的上帝面前，我或许会后悔。刚才那是约翰·威尔克斯·布思，伟大的莎士比亚演员。多米尼克，你在上一集中形容他非常具有“布赖恩·布莱斯德表演流派”的风格。他在1865年4月21日的日记中写下了这段话，当时他正因谋杀美国第十六任总统亚伯拉罕·林肯而四处逃亡。而谋杀林肯通常被视为美国历史上最具决定性的犯罪之一。
People say that it changed the course of the destiny of the United States. people ponder whether the dark and tragic story of American race relations throughout reconstruction into the 1950s and 60s. Might it have been different? Might the story of the former Rebel South have been transformed had Lincoln lived? And I guess we'll be trying to answer those questions later in today's episode. But for now, you left us at the end of the previous episode on an absolute cliffhanger. President and Mrs. Lincoln are sitting there enjoying a brilliant British comedy about an American hick who has come to lay claim to a stately home in England. I mean, couldn't be more fun. And then suddenly the party pooper,
人们说它改变了美利坚合众国命运的走向。人们在沉思，从重建时期到20世纪50和60年代，美国种族关系那段黑暗而悲惨的历史。是否本会有所不同？如果林肯活了下来，前南部邦联的故事会不会被改写？我想我们会在今天节目的后半部分尝试回答这些问题。但现在，你在上一集的结尾给我们留下了绝对巨大的悬念。林肯总统和夫人正坐在那里，津津有味地欣赏一部精彩的英国喜剧，讲的是一个美国乡巴佬来到英国继承一座庄园的故事。我是说，再有趣不过了。而就在这时，扫兴的人，
John Wilkes Booth, steps into Lincoln's box. Well, or does he leap, Tom? Because we discussed before that he loves leaping and capering when he's on stage. And that was the one thing I think that was missing from an excellent rendition of your reading from your reading from. You're reading from Booth's Journal. So just to remind people where we are, we are in Ford's Theatre on 10th Street in Washington, D.C. on the evening of Good Friday, the 4th of April, 1865, five days after Robert E. Lee surrendered at Appomattox. The city is unfet. Everybody's celebrating. Gas illuminations, great flags everywhere, all this. The theatre is very busy. The people in the theatre, interestingly, there's politicians, there's tourists. There are a lot of soldiers, union soldiers.
约翰·威尔克斯·布思，走进了林肯的包厢。嗯，或者说他是跳进去的，汤姆？因为我们之前讨论过，他上台时非常喜欢跳跃和嬉闹。而这恰好是你对布思日记朗读的一个精彩演绎中，我认为唯一缺少的一点。为了提醒大家我们身处何地，我们在华盛顿特区第十街的福特剧院，时间是1865年4月4日耶稣受难日，即罗伯特·E·李在阿帕玛克斯投降五天后的晚上。这座城市没有束缚。每个人都在庆祝。煤气照明灯，随处可见的大旗，诸如此类。剧院里非常热闹。有趣的是，剧院里有政客，有游客。还有很多士兵，联邦士兵。
Some of them are actually people who were at Appomattox, who are now on leave, officers on leave, and have come to the city to celebrate. A lot of them have been drawn to the theatre because they've heard that President and Mrs. Lincoln are coming with General and Mrs. Grant. They didn't show up because they basically hate Mrs. Lincoln. Or maybe there's a more suspicious reason.
其中一些人实际上是参加过阿帕玛克斯战役的人，现在正在休假，是休假的军官，来到这座城市庆祝。他们中很多人被吸引到剧院，因为他们听说林肯总统和夫人将与格兰特将军和夫人一同前来。他们没有出现，因为他们基本上讨厌林肯夫人。或者也许有更可疑的原因。
Yeah, Tom believes they're part of the conspiracy, which is an unusual view, but I'm happy to indulge it. The Lincoln's had arrived half an hour late. They're in the presidential box decorated with American flags and a portrait of the tax traitor. George Washington. And Dominic, it's about 12 feet above the stage, isn't it? So were you, for instance, to be very proficient at leaping, that might be a detail that would interest you. Might be a temptation, mind that. Just setting that up for later in the show.
对，汤姆认为他们是阴谋的一部分，这是一个不寻常的观点，但我很乐意纵容它。林肯夫妇迟到了半小时。他们坐在饰有美国国旗和税收叛国者乔治·华盛顿画像的总统包厢里。多米尼克，它离舞台大约有12英尺高，对吧？所以，如果你，比如说，非常擅长跳跃，那可能是一个你会感兴趣的细节。可能会是一种诱惑，注意那个。这是为节目后面做铺垫。
So if you went into the box, you would see, on your left, Abraham Lincoln in a rocking chair. Then his wife, Mary, in a smaller chair, and their friend Clara Harris in an armchair and behind them lounging on the sofa. Clara Harris is, on, say, Major Rathbone. Now, they have been enjoying the play a lot. They've been laughing. People have been watching Lincoln, of course, all the time. And they've seen him sort of sometimes, you know, in a reverie, lost in thought.
所以如果你走进包厢，你会看到，在你的左边，亚伯拉罕·林肯坐在一把摇椅上。然后是他的妻子玛丽，坐在一把较小的椅子上，他们的朋友克拉拉·哈里斯坐在单人沙发上，在他们身后斜倚在沙发上。克拉拉·哈里斯旁边，比如说，是雷斯本少校。现在，他们一直很喜欢这部戏。他们一直在笑。当然，人们一直在看着林肯。他们看到他有时，你知道的，陷入白日梦，陷入沉思。
Not surprising, given the burdens he has to carry. Can I just ask about Mrs. Lincoln? I mean, aside from the murder of her husband, does she enjoy the play? I think she did enjoy the play. People said they noticed a smiling a great deal. And this is unusual from her, because usually, as we discussed last time, she's something of a spitfire, always haranguing the wives of generals and stuff and having tantrums and storming off, so she doesn't do any of that on this occasion, which is nice,
考虑到他必须承担的重担，这并不奇怪。我能问一下林肯夫人吗？我是说，除了她丈夫被谋杀之外，她喜欢这出戏吗？我想她确实很喜欢这部戏。人们说他们注意到她笑了很多次。这很不寻常，因为通常情况下，正如我们上次讨论的那样，她有点像个火爆脾气，总是训斥将军们的妻子之类的人，发脾气然后摔门而去，所以在这次活动中她没有做任何这些事，这很好，
so it's a lovely evening out for her, I think, up to a certain point. Twice, Lincoln is interrupted by messages during the play, and these are brought by a White House messenger called Charles Forbes, who is sitting outside the entrance to the box, but neither of them are important enough to draw him away, so he's carrying on watching. What a shame. Now, a lot of the audience are watching Lincoln the whole time. So on the far side of the dress circle, there is a local saloon owner called James Ferguson. He's a huge Ulysses-S. Grant fan.
所以对她来说这是一个美好的夜晚，我想，在某种程度上。在剧目演出期间，林肯两次被信使送来的消息打断，这些消息由一个名叫查尔斯·福布斯的白宫信使带来，他就坐在包厢入口外面，但这两条消息都不重要，不足以把他叫走，所以他继续看着。真可惜。现在，许多观众一直在看着林肯。所以在正座观众席的远端，有一个当地的酒吧老板叫詹姆斯·弗格森。他是尤利西斯·S·格兰特的超级粉丝。
He was very excited about the thought of seeing Grant and was disappointed that he didn't turn up. But he's been watching Lincoln's box through his girlfriend's opera glasses. And so whenever Lincoln leans forward to see the play, this boat Ferguson can see him very clearly. And just after 10 o'clock, Ferguson notices a man with dark hair and a thick mustache, A very smartly dressed man holding his hat in his hand, walking along the back of the circle towards the presidential box. And the man gets to the door of the box and then he stops as if he's waiting for something. This man is the man you ventriloquized, so amusingly. And that is John Wilkes Booth.
他对外表见到格兰特感到非常兴奋，并对格兰特没有出现感到失望。但他一直通过女朋友的歌剧望远镜观察林肯的包厢。所以每当林肯前倾观看演出时，这个叫弗格森的家伙就能把他看得一清二楚。就在10点刚过，弗格森注意到一个黑发浓须的男子，一个衣着非常整洁、手里拿着帽子的男子，正沿着后排走廊朝总统包厢走去。这个人走到包厢门前，然后停了下来，好像在等待什么。这个人就是你模仿得如此滑稽的那个人。也就是约翰·威尔克斯·布思。
As we discussed last time, born in Maryland, a white supremacist, big fan of slavery, big fan of the Confederacy, well-known Shakespearean actor who has not fought for the South because he's a massive mummies boy and promised his mother he wouldn't join the army. But also because his career has been flourishing. Yes, his career has been flourishing. He's a successful actor. He has been alarmed, horrified by the news of Lee's surrender, but he had learned early that day that Lincoln would be at the theatre. We discussed last time he's hired a horse. He's smuggled a package out of the city with Confederate agents. And he has contacted three associates of his from a longstanding scheme to kidnap Lincoln.
正如我们上次讨论的那样，他出生于马里兰州，是一个白人至上主义者，奴隶制的坚定拥护者，邦联的坚定粉丝，一位著名的莎士比亚演员，他没有为南方战斗，因为他是个十足的妈宝，向母亲保证过不参军。但也因为他的事业一直蒸蒸日上。是的，他的事业一直蒸蒸日上。他是一个成功的演员。他对李将军投降的消息感到震惊和恐惧，但他那天早些时候得知林肯将出席剧院。我们上次讨论过，他租了一匹马。他与邦联特工一起将一个包裹偷运出城。他联系了三个老同谋，他们曾有一个绑架林肯的长期计划。
And these associates were a German carriage repairman called George Azarot, a pharmacist assistant called David Herald, and a Confederate secret agent called Lewis Powell. Now, I said last time that he briefed them about the plan, but I didn't say what the plan was. Now is the time to unveil Tom the conspiracy. The plan is that Azarot will kill Vice President Andrew Johnson, and Lewis Powell will kill Secretary of State William Seward. In other words, their plan is to decapitate the Northern League. leadership. Obviously, they don't think the Confederates are going to miraculously win the war, but maybe this will result in more favorable terms for the Confederacy now that the war is over. And Dominic, there is no hint that this is coming from the Confederate leadership itself.
这些同谋是一个名叫乔治·阿扎罗特的德国马车修理工，一个名叫大卫·赫尔德的药剂师助理，以及一个名叫路易斯·鲍威尔的邦联特工。现在，我上次说过他向他们简要介绍了这个计划，但我没有说计划是什么。现在是揭晓汤姆的阴谋的时候了。计划是阿扎罗特将杀死副总统安德鲁·约翰逊，路易斯·鲍威尔将杀死国务卿威廉·瑟华德。换句话说，他们的计划是斩首北方领导层。显然，他们并不认为邦联会奇迹般地赢得战争，但也许这会在战争结束后为邦联争取到更有利的条件。多米尼克，没有任何迹象表明这是由邦联领导层本身发起的。
People have talked a lot about this. Some historians think perhaps there is some greater involvement with the Confederate sort of secret service. No smoking gun. No, there's never been a smoking gun. And I think it's very unlikely that Jefferson Davis or the Confederate absolute high command would have authorized this actually, because I think they know at this point the war is over. So there's nothing in it for them? Not really. So let's return to that scene outside the box. The messenger Charles Forbes is still there, the White House messenger. John Wilkes Booth arrives at the box and he hands Forbes a card. We don't know what was on the card, but we do know. Booth is, of course, very well known. So Forbes probably assumed that the link
人们对此讨论了很多。一些历史学家认为，也许这与邦联某种秘密情报部门有更深层的联系。没有确凿证据。没有，从来没有什么确凿证据。而且我认为杰斐逊·戴维斯或邦联绝对最高指挥部授权这起谋杀的可能性非常小，因为我认为他们此时知道战争已经结束了。所以对他们来说有什么好处？没有真的好处。所以让我们回到包厢外的那个场景。信使查尔斯·福布斯还在那里，那个白宫信使。约翰·威尔克斯·布思来到包厢，递给福布斯一张卡片。我们不知道卡片上写了什么，但我们确实知道。布思当然非常有名。所以福布斯可能以为林肯
Jenkins had asked to see him or that, you know, a well-known actor arrives at the president's box. Let's say, I don't know, Matthew McFadion arrives at Keir Stama's box. Does Keir Stammer have any cultural enthusiasms at all? Probably not. I think if they're famous, he does. Really? I've been very clear about this, Tom. I do it. I'm very clear. I love Taylor Swift. I will accept a freebie to go and see her. Brilliant to have Keir Stammer on the show. Actually, he was on your brother's podcast, wasn't he? He was. My favourite war film is the longest. day. Is that what he said?
詹金斯曾要求见他，或者你知道的，一个著名的演员来到了总统包厢。比方说，我不知道，马修·麦克费登来到了基尔·斯塔默的包厢。基尔·斯塔默有任何文化爱好吗？可能没有。我想如果他们很有名，他就有。真的吗？对此我很清楚，汤姆。我有。我很清楚。我喜欢泰勒·斯威夫特。如果能免费去看她的演出，我欣然接受。很高兴请到基尔·斯塔默上节目。事实上，他上了你兄弟的播客，对吧？是的。我最喜欢的战争电影是《最长的一天》。他是这么说的吗？
No, I can't remember what it was. Bridge too far. We'd surely not express a preference out of terror than you'd say the wrong thing. Right. Anyway, Charles Forbes allows Booth to open the outer door. And so now Booth goes in. He's in this little vestibule outside Lincoln's box. He bars the outer door behind him with a piece of wood.
不，我不记得是什么了。遥远的桥。我们当然不会出于恐惧而表达偏好，否则你会说错话。对。无论如何，查尔斯·福布斯允许布思打开外门。所以现在布思进去了。他在林肯包厢外面的这个小前厅里。他用一块木头把身后的外门栓上。
And then he puts his eye to a peephole into Lincoln's box. Now, it's often said that he had bored the peephole earlier that day. In fact, there was a very, very details, an actually brilliant book on John Walsh Booth by Michael Kaufman called American Brutus, one for you, Tom. And in that book, Kaufman quotes, the son of the theatre manager Harry Ford, who wrote in 1962,
然后他把眼睛贴在通往林肯包厢的窥视孔上。现在，人们常说他在那天早些时候钻了这个窥视孔。事实上，有一本非常非常详细、关于约翰·威尔克斯·布思的精彩著作，是迈克尔·考夫曼写的《美国布鲁图斯》，这本书送给你，汤姆。在那本书里，考夫曼引用了剧院经理哈里·福特的儿子在1962年写的话，
that Booth had nothing to do with this people. It was always there that the theatre manager had bought it himself so that bodyguards, if they were there, could see into the presidential box and that Lincoln's entourage could see what he was up to. Anyway, Booth looks to this hole. And you can see there are four people in the box. There's Lincoln, the rocking chair, there's Mary, there's Clara Harris, there's Major Rathbone on this sofa.
布思跟这个窥视孔没有任何关系。它一直都在那里，是剧院经理自己买的，以便保镖（如果他们在的话）能够看到总统包厢里面，也为了林肯的随从能随时看到他在做什么。无论如何，布思看着这个洞。你可以看到包厢里有四个人。有坐在摇椅上的林肯，有玛丽，有克拉拉·哈里斯，还有在这个沙发上的雷斯本少校。
And now Booth waits. He doesn't go in. He has thought about this quite carefully. He has an escape plan. He knows the moment he wants to strike. Because he's an actor, he knows this play very well. He knows there will be a perfect moment when there's going to be a great punchline. The stage will be almost deserted.
现在布思在等待。他没有进去。他对此考虑得相当仔细。他有一个逃跑计划。他知道他想动手的那一刻。因为他是个演员，他对这出戏非常熟悉。他知道会有一个完美的时刻，届时会有一个巨大的笑点。舞台上几乎空无一人。
Everybody will be laughing. and he can make his move. And this is the hilarious stretch of dialogue that you rendered in the previous episode, but it's so funny that I think we should hear it again. Oh, wonderful. So it's 10.15. We're at three, scene two.
每个人都在笑。而他可以采取行动了。这就是你在上一集中重现的那段滑稽的对话，但它太搞笑了，我觉得我们应该再听一遍。哦，太棒了。现在是10点15分。我们在第三幕第二场。
And Harry Hawke, maybe Tom, you'd like to do Harry Hawke, and I'll play Mrs. Mount Chessington. So Harry Hawke is playing the American cousin, and he's arguing with this woman called Mrs. Mount Chessington, so Lady Bracknell figure. And she storms off the stage and she says, I am aware, Mr.
哈里·霍克，也许汤姆，你想演哈里·霍克，我来演芒切辛顿夫人。所以哈里·霍克饰演美国表亲，他正在和这个叫芒切辛顿夫人的女人争吵，这是一个类似布拉克内尔夫人的角色。她气冲冲地离开舞台说：“我知道，特伦查尔先生，你不习惯上流社会的礼仪。”“不知道上流社会的礼仪，是吧？嗯，我想你足够懂得以至于能把你里外翻个底朝天，老姑娘。你这个可恶的、钓金龟老套子，你。”每个人都为这段绝对精彩的机智对答爆发出大笑，理当如此。正是在那一刻，汤姆，约翰·威尔克斯·布思，他推开包厢的门，从口袋里掏出一把德林杰手枪，朝着亚伯拉罕·林肯的摇椅迈出了一步，将枪口对准林肯的脑后，
Trenchard, you are not used to the manners of good society. Don't though the manners of good society, eh? Well, I guess you know enough to turn you inside out, old girl. You suck, dollar-jasing old man-trap, you. And everybody roars with laughter at this absolutely tremendous repartee, as they would. And it is at that moment, Tom, that John Wilkes Booth, he opens the door of the box, he takes out a derringer pistol from his pocket, he takes a single step towards Abraham Lincoln's rocking chair, he levels it at the back of
然后开枪。零距离。零距离。现在，枪声一响，雷斯本少校立即跳了起来，他突然意识到发生了什么。包厢里有一个黑影。他向那个黑影扑去，然后又退缩了，因为他看到了布思另一只手里刀子的寒光。
Lincoln's head, and he fires. Point blank range. Point blank range. Now, as soon as the shot rings out, Major Rathbone leaps to his feet, he suddenly realizes what's happening. There's a dark figure in the box. He lunges towards the figure, and then he shrinks back because he sees the glint of a knife in Booth's other hand.
而布思也是，他一只手开枪，然后用另一只手攻击，
And Booth, too, he's fired with one hand, and then with the other hand, he strikes. with the dagger into Rathbone's arm, and he slices through his arm. Rathbone falls backwards towards the sofa. This is all in the second. The two women are so stunned. They're obviously deafened by the shot and just amazed. They have not really reacted. So this is when Booth pulls off the really sort of remarkable bit of his plan. He strides past them to the rail of the box. He puts one hand on the rail, and then he vaults over the rail down 12 feet. feet and lands on the stage. Now, it's often said that he caught a spur in his boot on one of the flags decorating the
用匕首刺向雷斯本的手臂，划破了他的胳膊。雷斯本向后倒向沙发。这一切都发生在短短一秒内。两个女人震惊极了。她们显然被枪声震得耳鸣，惊呆了。她们根本没有反应过来。这就是布思完成他计划中真正非凡一部分的时刻。他大步从她们身边走过，走到包厢的栏杆前。他把一只手搭在栏杆上，然后越过栏杆，从12英尺高的地方跳了下去，落在了舞台上。现在，人们常说他的靴子马刺挂在了装饰包厢的一面旗帜上。事实上，只有目击者，也就是我之前提到的那个拿着歌剧望远镜的家伙詹姆斯·弗格森，他是唯一一个说自己看到这一幕的人。没有其他人说他们看到了。他自己受伤了吗？是的。他确实受伤了。有些说法称，因为他这个挂住马刺的动作，他随后非常狼狈地摔倒在
box. Actually, only one witness, this bloke that I mentioned earlier with the opera glasses, James Ferguson, he's the only person who said he saw this happen. Nobody else said they saw it. Is he hurt himself at all? Yes. So he definitely does. Some accounts say, because he did this caught his spur, he then fell very awkwardly onto
舞台上。我想如果你挂了马刺，你摔倒的姿态会比他实际摔得要狼狈得多。我认为他摔倒时，落地姿势稍微有些笨拙，因为这是一个相当大的落差，他实际上骨折了腿，正如我们接下来将看到的。但有趣的是，对于当时目击者所发生的事情，有非常非常多的说法。没有一个人的说法是完全一样的。所以对于听过我们肯尼迪系列节目的听众来说，你们会对目击证词中的出入印象深刻，这完全是一样的，历史往往就是这样，
the stage. I think if you'd caught your spell, you'd fall much more awkwardly than he falls. I think he falls, he lands slightly awkwardly, it's quite a big drop, and he effectively fractures his leg, as we will discover. But the interesting thing is at this point, there are many, many accounts of what happened from witnesses at the time. None of them tell the same thing. So for people who listen to our JFK series, who, you know, was struck by the discrepancies
肯尼迪遇刺案并没有什么独特之处。人们甚至对布思说了什么都无法达成一致。演员哈里·霍克当时正准备下台。他确信布思在准备跳跃时大喊了“暴君永远悲惨”（Sic semper tyrannis）这个词。霍克说，然后他跳上了舞台。他直起身子，把匕首举过头顶，
in the eyewitness accounts, this is exactly the same thing as it is so often in history. there's nothing unique about the Kennedy murder. People didn't even agree on what Booth said. Harry Hawke, the actor, who was just about to walk off stage. He was convinced that as Booth was preparing to jump, he shouted the word sick, Semper, Tyrannis. Hawke said, then he jumped onto the stage. He straightened up, he raised his dagger over his head,
大喊：“南方必将自由。”但其他目击者说：“不，根本不是这样的。他落地后只喊了‘暴君永远悲惨’。”还有人说：“不，他根本没说那个。他说的是南方应当复仇。”或者有些人只是说，他喊道：“我做到了！”然后跑下了舞台。所以，如果你读到一个绝对权威的说法，你知道的，你花钱买书，自己做选择吧。
and he shouted, the South shall be free. But other witnesses said, no, that's not right at all. he only shouted six Semper Tyrannis, so always to tyrants, once he'd landed on the stage. And other people said, well, no, he didn't say that at all. He said the South should be avenged. Or some people just said, he said, I've done it! And then ran off the stage. So, you know, if you read a definitive account, you know, you paid your money and takes your choice, really.
没有理由相信某一个版本而不是另一个版本。我想肯尼迪遇刺案最大的不同在于，如果他是零距离射杀林肯，那么谁干的以及子弹从哪里来，这是毫无疑问的。没错，一点疑问也没有。唯一所有人一致同意、真正一致同意的是，一旦他落在舞台上并说了他说的那些话之后，他转过身，跑进侧幕条，跑进黑暗中，然后就消失得无影无踪了。
There's no reason to trust one version rather than another. I suppose the one big difference with the Kennedy assassination is that if he shot Lincoln at point blank range, There's no question about who did it and where the bullet came from. Exactly, not at all. The only thing that everybody agrees, everyone really agrees, is that once he's landed on the stage and said whatever he said, he turned, he ran into the wings, into the darkness, and he vanished from sight.
所以他跑了，但他的腿可能骨折了？所以他是靠肾上腺素支撑的，还是？靠肾上腺素支撑的，我想。因为正如你将发现的，他不仅是在跑。他接下来骑了几个小时的马。所以我们将在下半场继续讲述约翰·威尔克斯·布思的故事，但现在，让我们留在剧院里。大多数人的反应是彻底的震惊和困惑。起初，大多数人以为那是戏里的一部分，或者他们认为这是为了庆祝亚伯拉罕·林肯出席而搞的一个稍微有些恶俗的噱头。
So he ran, but he's fractured his leg, perhaps? So he's fired by adrenaline or? Fire by adrenaline, I think. Because as you'll find out, he doesn't just run. He then rides for hours. So we'll pick up when John Wilkes Booth's story in the second half, but for now, let's stay in the theatre. Most people's reaction is total shock and confusion. Now, at first, most people thought it was part of the play, or they thought it was a slightly tasteless stunt to Mark Abraham Lincoln's presence.
或者很多人实际上说：“我以为有什么东西在后面倒了。我听到一声巨响，我以为是礼堂里有什么东西倒了，或者舞台的一部分倒塌了。”你知道，谁知道那是什么呢。剧院的工作人员一直透过窗户之类的东西半信半疑地看着，当他们看到竟然是布思本人在舞台上时，他们惊呆了。其中一个人甚至脱口而出。他说：“天哪，约翰·布思疯了吗？”所以这有点像布拉德·皮特突然出现在舞台上挥舞着一把枪。
Or a lot of people actually said, I thought something had fallen over at the back. I heard a big bang and I thought something like a fallen over in the auditorium, had a bit of the stage fallen over. You know, who knows what it was. The theatre staff, who have been half watching through kind of windows and things, they were stunned when they saw Booth of all people on stage. One of them actually burst out. He said, by God, is John Booth crazy? So it's kind of like Brad Pitt suddenly, appearing on the stage and waving a gum.
完全是这样。然后他们听到总统包厢里传来尖叫声。当人们听到尖叫声时，他们就会恐慌，然后开始奔跑。所以出现了一阵骚乱。有些人冲上舞台，试图上台去追约翰·威尔克斯·布思，有些人只是逃离剧院，因为他们以为受到了全面的袭击，还有人试图进入林肯的包厢。在包厢里，玛丽·林肯俯身在丈夫身上，她泣不成声，说道：“跟我说话，跟我说话，”
Exactly. Now, then they heard people screaming from the president's box. When people hear screaming, then they panic and people start to run. So there's a bit of a stampede. Some people are charging onto the stage, trying to get onto the stage, after John Wilk's booth, some people are just running out of the theatre because they think there's a general attack, other people trying to get into Lincoln's box. In the box, Mary Lincoln is bent over her husband, she's sobbing, she's saying, talk to me, talk to me,
诸如此类的话，因为她瘫倒在他的椅子上。你现在是要说一些关于她的可怕的话吗？还是你会对这个可怜的女人产生一丝怜悯？不，我为她感到难过。我为她感到难过。林肯垂死之际，她其实并没有得到很好的对待，正如我们等会儿将看到的。你为她感到难过，对吧，汤姆？我是。是的。很好。这很能反映你的为人。雷斯本少校处于休克状态。他的胳膊几乎被砍断了，不是吗？基本上是这样。他的手臂上有一道大大的伤口，鲜血渗进他的袖子里。
all this, because she's slumped in his chair. Are you going to say something horrid about her now? Or are you going to feel a measure of pity for this poor woman? No, I feel sorry for her. I feel sorry for her. She's not really well treated, actually, as Lincoln is dying, as we shall see. You feel sorry for it, don't you, Tom? I do. Yeah. Lovely. Reflects very well on you. Major Rathbone is in shock. He's had his arm chopped off, hasn't he? Basically. It's a big slice down his arm and there's blood soaking into his sleeve.
现在，尽管他失血过多，但他依然保持着清醒的头脑，试图打开包厢的门，却发现布思把它卡住了。外面还有其他人用力砸门。因此，他们合力把门打开了，人们冲进了包厢。现在，其中一个人是一个年轻的医生，好像才拿到行医资格几周，名叫查尔斯·利尔。他20多岁。
Now, even though he's losing a lot of blood, he has the presence of mind to try and open the door of the box, and he realizes that Booth has jammed it. So there are other people hammering on the door. So between them, they managed to get the door open, and people burst into the box. Now, one of them is a young doctor, who's only been qualified for a few weeks, I think, called Charles Leal. He's in his 20s. and he's joined by an older doctor from the army, a Signal Corps surgeon called Charles Taft.
还有一位来自军队的年长医生，信号兵团的外科医生查尔斯·塔夫特也加入了进来。
Leal, the younger man, is the first to Lincoln's body, and he finds the president, his comatosis unconscious, he's breathing, very laboured breathing. And interestingly, although it's point-brank range, Leal can't actually find the wound at first because it's only a small pistol. And at first, because everybody had seen Booth lifting, waving this bloody knife on stage,
年轻的利尔第一个来到林肯的遗体旁，他发现总统处于昏迷状态，不省人事，他在呼吸，呼吸非常困难。有趣的是，尽管是零距离射击，利尔起初甚至找不到伤口，因为那只是一把小手枪。起初，由于大家都看到布思在舞台上举着、挥舞着这把带血的刀，
they assume that Lincoln has been stabbed. And it's interesting that, isn't it? I'd never thought that. But of course, Caesar had been murdered with a dagger. Yeah. So for a Shakespeare actor to stand on a stage and wave a dagger is much more natural than for him, say, to wave a gun. Yeah, I guess so.
他们以为林肯是被刺伤的。这很有趣，不是吗？我从没想过这一点。但当然，凯撒是被匕首谋杀的。对。所以对于一个莎士比亚演员来说，站在舞台上挥舞匕首要比挥舞枪自然得多。是的，我想是的。
I guess so. I hadn't thought that, actually, that that's the thing that he waves. The semiotics of it is much more Shakespearean. It is. Absolutely, it is much more classical. So with some soldiers, Leal gets Lincoln to the floor. They still can't find the wound. They're cutting off his shirt, assuming he's been stabbed.
我想是的。我之前没想到这一点，原来他挥舞的是匕首。这其中的符号学要莎士比亚得多。确实如此，它绝对要古典得多。于是利尔和一些士兵把林肯放倒在地上。他们仍然找不到伤口。他们割开他的衬衫，以为他被刺伤了。
and then Leal runs his hand through Lincoln's hair and he finds a bullet hole at the back of his head or a small bullet hole with a swelling around it and the blood's already started to cloth and as Leal ruffles through kind of Lincoln's hair the clot opens up and blood pours out but at that point Lincoln starts to breathe more easily now at this point the soldiers are already saying
然后利尔的手掠过林肯的头发，在脑后发现了一个弹孔，或者说是一个周围肿胀的小弹孔，血已经开始凝固了。当利尔拨弄林肯的头发时，血块裂开，鲜血涌了出来，但就在那时，林肯开始呼吸得更顺畅了。此时士兵们已经开始说
we've got to get the president back to the White House and the surgeon the army surgeon Dr Taft steps in he says listen I know I'm talking about we cannot take him there you can't move him a long way where we should take him is the nearest house and they want to do this because they feel it would be vulgar for a president to die in a theatre they already know he's basically dead this is so interesting this is Michael Kaufman's theory because Calphan points out at this point just to be clear both of these doctors are in no doubt whatsoever that Lincoln is a dead man there is no way if you've been shot in
我们必须把总统送回白宫，而外科医生、陆军外科医生塔夫特博士介入了，他说：听着，我知道我在说什么，我们不能把他带到那去，你不能把他运送那么远的距离，我们应该带他去最近的房子。他们想这么做是因为他们觉得让一个总统死在剧院里太粗俗了。他们已经知道他基本上没救了。这太有趣了，这是迈克尔·考夫曼的理论，因为考夫曼指出，在此期间——为了说清楚——这两位医生都毫无疑问地认为林肯已经是个死人了。如果你后脑中枪，而且是零距离，你绝无可能存活。所以他们知道他快死了，但他们不想让他在耶稣受难日死在一个戏院里。这太不得体了。不得体就是这个词，是的。于是他们组织了一支担架队，把林肯抬出包厢，走下楼梯，穿过门厅，穿过马路来到最近的房子，那是一间寄宿公寓——具有讽刺意味的是，显然因为它靠近剧院，非常受演员欢迎——由一个名叫威廉·彼得森的德国裁缝经营。他们把他抬到一楼的一间后卧室里。林肯个子太高了，身材非常高大，
the back of the head, a point-blank range that you will possibly survive. So they know he's dying, but they don't want him to die on Good Friday in a playhouse. It's so indecorous. Indecorous is the word, yeah. So they organise a bearer party, and they take Lincoln out of the box, down the stairs, through the sort of foyer and across the road to the nearest house, which is a lodging house, ironically, obviously because it's close to the theatre, very popular with actors run by a German tailor called William Peterson and they take him to a back bedroom on the ground floor and Lincoln is such a long man, a very tall man
以至于他放不下那张床，所以他们不得不让他斜着躺在床上。现在，玛丽·林肯踉踉跄跄地跟在他们后面。她完全处于恍惚状态，毫不奇怪，处于休克状态。克拉拉·哈里斯和这个可怜的雷斯本少校也是如此，他差点丧命，因为布思实际上割断了他的一条动脉。
that he won't fit on the bed so they have to lie him diagonally across the bed. Now, Mary Lincoln kind of trails behind them. She's in a total daze, not surprisingly, in a state of shock. So are Clara Harris and this poor bloke major rathbone who basically comes very close to death because Booth had actually severed an artery
他的胳膊这时正在被包扎。他的胳膊最终被包扎好了。但实际上，玛丽·林肯再也无法正视克拉拉和雷斯本少校了，我想。她把他们与那个夜晚联系在一起。无论如何，士兵们最终把玛丽·林肯带过了街。有一段时间，她只是独自站在前客厅里，整个人处于休克状态。我真的很为她难过。她失去了儿子。
And his arm being patched up by this point. His arm is eventually patched up. But actually, Mary Lincoln could never look at Clara and Major Rathbone again, I think. She associated them with that night. Anyway, the soldiers eventually get Mary Lincoln across the street. And for a time, she just stands on her own in the front parlour, kind of just standing in shock. I feel really sorry for her. She's lost her son.
现在她又失去了丈夫。而你所能做的，就是抱怨她偶尔对那些和她丈夫一同骑马的迷人女性有点挑剔。我完全是林肯夫人这一边的。我在上一集里抱怨过，但这一集没有。她顺着走廊去找她的丈夫。人们形容她泣不成声，用他们的话说，处于“极度的痛苦中”。鲜血和脑组织正慢慢从他的头部渗出，
Now she's lost her husband. And all you can do is moan about the fact that she's occasionally a little bit sniffy about very attractive women riding with her husband. I'm totally team Mrs. Lincoln. I moaned in the last episode, but not in this one. She goes down the hall to her husband. People described her sobbing in, in quote, extreme anguish. There's blood and brain tissue slowly leaking out of his head,
但她还是吻着他的头，恳求他说些什么。此时，无数的人挤满了房间。尤其是战争部长埃德温·斯坦顿，他接管了指挥。他们此时都非常清楚林肯将要死去。他们叫来了他21岁的大儿子罗伯特。他一直作为陆军上尉在格兰特将军的参谋部服役。他情绪崩溃了，但他觉得自己必须表现得很坚强，你知道的，他表现得很像个男子汉。
but she's kissing his head nonetheless, and she's begging him to speak. Now, at this point, tons of people have crowded into the room. Above all, the Secretary of War, Edwin Stanton, who takes charge. They all are very clear at this point that Lincoln will die. they call for his son Robert, who's 21, his oldest son. He's been serving on General Grant's staff as an army captain. He breaks down, but he feels he has to sort of present a stoical, you know, he manns up as it way.
他现在是家里的顶梁柱了。他现在是家里的顶梁柱了。他平静了下来。他实际上说：我想把我母亲的一个朋友、一位名叫伊丽莎白·迪克森的参议员妻子请到这里来，来安慰我母亲。但玛丽一直闯回房间，恳求她的丈夫醒过来，为了孩子们的活下去——这实际上是弗朗茨·斐迪南对索菲说过的话，如果你还记得他们在萨拉热窝垂死的时候的话。
He's now the head of the house. He's now the head of the house. And he composes himself. And he actually says, I want to get one of my mother's friends, who's a senator's wife called Elizabeth Dixon, to come over here and to calm my mother down. But Mary keeps kind of bursting back into the room and begging her husband. to wake up and live for the sake of the children, which actually what Franz Ferdinand said to Sophie, if you remember when they were dying in Sarajevo.
现在我们有了医生的记录，其中一位医生的记录。他做了相当详细的记录，记录了林肯整夜的病情恶化。他非常安静。他只是，失去知觉，呼吸极其困难。他们真的只是在等待终局。他们叫来了参议院的牧师，即参议院牧师格利博士，他在三点半作了最后一次祈祷，但林肯又活了大约三个小时。
Now we have the doctor's notes, one of the doctor's notes. He made quite detailed notes of Lincoln's sort of decline across the night. He was very quiet. He's just, his unconscious, breathing with great difficulty. They're really just all waiting for the end. They called for a chaplain from the Senate, the Senate chaplain, who's called Dr. Gurley, and he said his last prayers at half-bust three, but Lincoln lived for another three hours or so.
早晨七点钟，他的呼吸变得非常微弱，他们都知道末日近了。就在那时，玛丽回来了，她意识到他快要死了，她发出一阵尖叫，扑倒在地上。而埃德温·斯坦顿——我认为公正地说，他并不像你那样同情林肯夫人——他气急败坏，大喊道：“把那个女人带出去，不要再让她进来。”哦，好吧。所以他对悲伤寡妇的处理方式很像你。我从来没有遇到过带着悲伤寡妇的情况，汤姆。我是说，我不希望为了一个悲伤寡妇的缘故而……迪克森太太把玛丽带了出去。玛丽哭得很大声，其实是在责备自己。
At seven o'clock in the morning, his breathing became very ragged, and they all knew the end was near. And at that point, Mary came back in, she realized he was about to die, and she had a kind of shrieking fit and threw herself onto the ground. And Edwin Stanton, who does not share your view, I think it's fair to say, Mrs. Lincoln, he went ballistic, and he shouted, take that woman out and do not let her in here again. Oh, right. So his approach to the grieving widow is very much yours. I've never been in that circumstance with a grieving widow, Tom. I mean, I hate for the sake of a grieving widow that you're not. Mrs. Dixon took Mary out. Mary is sobbing very loudly and actually blaming herself.
她说：“哦，天哪，难道是我害死了我的丈夫吗？”因为，当然，是她劝他去剧院的。是的。这是一个悲惨的故事。我认为她才是真正的英雄。好吧，我们走着瞧。7点22分，林肯呼出了最后一口气。然后一切就结束了。
She says, oh my God, and have I given my husband to die? Because, of course, she'd persuaded him to go to the theatre. Yeah. It's a tragic story. I think she's the real hero of this. Well, we'll see. At 722, Lincoln takes his final breath. And then that's the end.
埃德温·斯坦顿带着真正好莱坞式的风格说：“现在他属于时代了。”所以他是彩排过的吗？“我的船长，我的船长”——是的。玛丽此时不在房间里。牧师走进客厅，把这个消息告诉玛丽，她对著他尖叫，她说：“你为什么不让我知道他快死了，”
and Edwin Stanton with properly Hollywood flair just says now he belongs to the ages so was he rehearsed captain my captain yeah Mary's out of the room at this point the chaplain goes into the parlour and to tell Mary the news and she shrieks at him she says why didn't you let me know that he was dying
“你为什么不告诉我？”格利对她说：“你的朋友们认为这不是最好的，你必须顺从上帝的意志，你必须冷静下来，信仰你的上帝和你的朋友。”汤姆，你对玛丽感到很同情，但我必须说，在这之后，她稍微有点丢脸，因为当她搬出白宫时，她偷了相当于70个打包箱的东西。
why didn't you tell me girly says to her your friends thought it wasn't best you must be resigned to the will of God you must be calm and trust in your God and in your friends now Tom you feel very sorry for Mary but I have to say, after this, she slightly disgraces herself because when she moves out of the White House, she steals 70 packing cases worth of stuff.
她偷了银器、勺子、地毯和窗帘。她实际上是美国历史上的“罗贝尔娅·萨克维尔-巴金斯”。我觉得这太严厉了。我其实查过“罗贝尔娅·萨克维尔-巴金斯”。不，不。博德利图书馆里的林肯夫人。我读到她余生都穿着丧服，就像维多利亚女王一样。
She steals the silver, the spoons, the carpets, and the curtains. She is, in fact, the Labilia-Sackville-Baggans of American history. I think that's harsh. I actually looked up. Lebelia-Sat-Vell-Baggans. No, no. Mrs. Lincoln in the Bodleon. And I read that she wore mourning for the rest of her life, like Queen Victoria.
维多利亚女王写了一封非常同情的信给她。我认为这很好地反映了维多利亚女王的同情心，不像你，把她比作《指环王》中不那么讨喜的角色之一。我想听众会从中得出自己的结论。如果维多利亚女王发现那些银器的东西，如果她知道那些该死的勺子，她就会改变主意了。我不这么认为。
And Queen Victoria wrote a very sympathetic letter to her. And I think it reflects well on Queen Victoria that she was sympathetic, unlike you who has compared her to one of the less appealing figures from Lord of the Rings. And I think listeners will draw their own conclusions from this. Queen Victoria would have changed her tune. If she'd found out that stuff about the silver, if she'd known about the flipping spoons, she'd have changed her mind. I don't think so.
对我来说，你说她是真正的受害者。对我来说，最悲伤的部分其实是他们的儿子塔德或塔迪。塔迪当时12岁。我们在上一集中谈到过他。他有腭裂，说话有很严重的障碍。所以他总的来说经历挺坎坷的。他不久前刚庆祝完12岁生日。他没有和他们一起去看戏，因为这对一个12岁的孩子来说是一出非常无聊的戏。
For me, you say she's the real victim. For me, the saddest part is actually Tad or Taddy, their son. Taddy was 12. We talked about him in the last episode. He had a cleft palate, very serious problems with his speech. So he's had a kind of rough deal generally. He's only recently celebrated his 12th birthday. And he didn't come with them to the play because it's a very boring play for a 12-year-old.
他的家庭教师带他去了另一家剧院看《阿拉丁》。有一幕，玛丽说：“哦，我们派人把塔迪叫来吧，因为他父亲非常爱塔迪。他听到塔迪的声音就会醒来的，”但后来她转念一想。哦不，可怜的塔迪，你知道的，他会太难过的。现在塔迪，这是一个可怕的场景。他在看《阿拉丁》时，剧院经理停止了演出，宣布总统被枪击了。我是说，想象一下身为塔迪的感受。他当然歇斯底里，被带回了白宫，泪流满面。他似乎在一夜之间说服自己他的父亲会活下来。所以当人们第二天开始返回
His tutor had taken him to another theatre to see Aladdin. And at one point, Mary said, oh, let's send for Taddy because his father loves Taddy so much. He will wake up when he hears Taddy. his voice, but then she thought better of it. Oh no, poor Taddy, you know, he'll be too upset. Now Taddy, it's a terrible scene. He's at Aladdin when the theatre managers stop the play and announce that the president has been shot. I mean, imagine being Taddy. He is hysterical, of course, and he's taken back to the White House and floods of tears. He seems to have convinced himself overnight that his father would live. So when people start returning to the
房子时，他在问：“我的爸爸在哪儿？我的爸爸在哪儿？”牧师格利牧师说：“塔迪，你的爸爸死了。”塔迪崩溃了。“哦，我的父亲死了。我该怎么办？”哦，他说，他在恳求他的母亲。“别死，妈妈。别死。我会被孤零零留下的。我会被孤零零留下的。”第二天，满怀祝愿的人们涌向房子。塔迪对其中一个人说：“你认为我父亲去天堂了吗？”“毫无疑问，”那个祝愿的人说。塔迪说：“那我很高兴他去了那里，因为他自从来到华盛顿后就再也没有快乐过。这里不是个好地方。”好了，为了把这部分故事收尾。接下来的几天里，白宫外面挤满了啜泣的人群。海军部长吉迪恩·韦尔斯——他是这方面绝佳的资料来源——对人群中的非裔美国人、黑人印象尤深。“他们绝望的悲伤比其他任何事情都更触动我。”
house the next day, he's saying, where's my par? Where's my par? And Chaplain, Reverend Gurley, says, Taddy, your pa is dead. And Taddy breaks down. Oh, my father is dead. What shall I do? Oh, he says, he's begging his mother. Don't die, Ma. Don't die. I'll be left alone. I'll be left alone. And the next day, well-wishers are descending on the house. And Taddy said to one of them, do you think my father has gone to heaven? I have not a doubt of it, the well-wisher said. And Taddy said, that I'm glad he's gone there, for he never was happy after he came here to Washington. This was not a good. good place for him. So, I'm just to tie up this bit of the story. For the next few days, the crowds and crowds of people sobbing outside the White House, the Secretary of the Navy Gideon Wells, who's a brilliant source on this, was struck above all by their African Americans, by the black people in the crowds. Their hopeless grief affects me more than almost anything else.
“那些坚强勇敢的男人们在遇到我时哭了。”林肯的葬礼于19日在白宫东厅举行，这天实际上是内战中最早伤亡的周年纪念日——这些伤亡发生在巴尔的摩的一群暴徒袭击从马萨诸塞州前往前线的南下部队时。林肯的遗体停放在国会大厦供人瞻仰。护灵的是美国第22有色人种步兵团。吉迪恩·韦尔斯再次写到了人群中黑人的悲伤。他说：“哀悼他们视之为恩人和父亲的人的离去。”然后他的遗体离开了国会大厦。
Those strong and brave men wept when I met them. Lincoln's funeral was held in the East Room of the White House on the 19th. of April, which was actually the anniversary of the very first deaths in the Civil War, deaths which happened when a mob in Baltimore had attacked troops that were heading south to the front from Massachusetts. Lincoln's body lay in state in the capital. It was escorted by the 22nd United States Colored Infantry. Again, Gideon Wells wrote about the grief of the black people in the crowd. He said, bewailing the loss of him whom they regarded as a benefactor and a father. And then his body left the capital.
两天后踏上了乘火车返回家乡伊利诺伊州的旅程，同样由黑人部队护送，黑人部队悲痛欲绝，许多贵宾都为之动容。火车行程历时两周，特意沿着林肯1861年当选总统时的路线原路返回。五百万人排在铁轨两旁，或在火车在各个城市停留时排队瞻仰棺木。人们挥舞着旗帜。他们唱着赞美诗，点燃篝火，但最重要的是，人们对洪水般啜泣的旁观者数量感到震惊。多米尼克，我可以问一下吗？
told two days later for the journey by rail to his home state of Illinois, again escorted by black troops, and their black troops were so grief-stricken that sort of VIPs, many of them were moved to tears. The rail journey took two weeks and it was retracing deliberately the journey that Lincoln had made when he became president in 1861. Five million people line the tracks or queued up to see the coffin when it stopped in various cities. People would wave flags. They'd sing hymns, they lit bonfires, but above all, people are struck by the number of sort of onlookers in floods and floods of tears. And Dominic, can I ask?
请说。林肯死在耶稣受难日这一事实。人们会得出显而易见的相似之处吗？当然。有很多关于他是一个像基督一样的人物的内容。绝对的。所以这里面有一种宗教维度。
Yeah. The fact that Lincoln was killed on Good Friday. Yeah. Do people draw the obvious parallel? Of course. Lots of stuff about it being a Christ-like figure. Absolutely. So there's a kind of religious dimension to all of this.
对。事实上林肯是在耶稣受难日被杀的。对。人们会得出显而易见的平行联想吗？当然会。有很多关于他是一个基督式人物的说法。完全如此。所以这一切都有某种宗教维度。
There is a religious dimension. And, of course, for example, we talked about African-American mourners. You know, African-American culture is absolutely steeped in scripture. at this point in the 19th century. So yes, very much. But also the sense of life coming from death, perhaps. I guess so. I guess so. The last on the 3rd of May 1865, the train carrying Abraham Lincoln pulls into Springfield, Illinois, and for the last time, he has come home. Goodness, Dominic. Not a dry eye in the house. But while all this has been going on, there's a manhunt going on as well. I'm presuming that, Dominic, that we will come to this story
宗教维度也是有的。当然，例如，我们谈到了非裔美国人的哀悼者。你知道，在19世纪的这个时候，非裔美国文化深深浸透在《圣经》之中。所以是的，确实如此。但或许也有那种生命从死亡中诞生的感觉。我想是的。我想是的。1865年5月3日，最后一辆载着亚伯拉罕·林肯的列车驶入伊利诺伊州斯普林菲尔德，他最后一次回家了。天哪，多米尼克。全场无不落泪。但正当这一切发生的时候，一场搜捕行动也在进行中。我猜，多米尼克，我们接下来会讲到这个故事
and the remarkable fate of John Wilkes Booth, and most excitingly of all, the reappearance on the rest is history of a top eunuch. So all of that is coming after the break. This episode is brought to you by Surf Shark. Now, had Mary Queen of Scots been just a little bit more careful
以及约翰·威尔克斯·布斯那不同寻常的结局，而最让人兴奋的是，“历史其余部分”节目里一位顶级太监的再度登场。所有这些都将在中场休息后为您呈现。本期节目由Surf Shark赞助播出。现在，如果苏格兰女王玛丽再稍微谨慎一点
with her correspondence, then she might well have avoided becoming a cautionary tale of treason. So she slipped her ciphered letters into beer barrels. Methods today have changed, but the risk of interception, of course, always remains. Your information is more vulnerable than ever, and perhaps especially when it's online. Trackers and advertisers and apps collecting your data all the time. And if you're using public Wi-Fi, then your activity can be monitored by anyone who is sharing the network that you are on.
对待她的书信，那么她很可能会避免成为叛国行为的警世故事。于是她把加密信件塞进了啤酒桶里。如今的方法变了，但被拦截的风险当然一直都在。你的信息比以往任何时候都更加脆弱，特别是当它在网上时。追踪者、广告商和应用程序一直在收集你的数据。如果你在使用公共Wi-Fi，那么你的活动可能会被你所连接的网络上的任何人监视。
And this is where Surf Shark comes in. It's a VPN that encrypts your internet connection, thereby keeps your personal data secure. So you can also change your digital location, giving you access to your favourite sites and streaming services wherever you are. So protect your data, browse securely from anywhere, no cipher, no career, certainly no beer barrel required. Go to surfshark.com slash TRIH or you can use the code TRIH at the checkout to get four extra months of Surfshock VPN plus a 30-day money-back guarantee. Hello, I'm William Drimple. And I'm Anita Arndon, we're the hosts of another goalhanger show, Empire.
这就是Surf Shark派上用场的地方。它是一个VPN，可以加密你的互联网连接，从而保护你的个人数据的安全。因此你还可以更改你的数字位置，无论你在哪里都可以访问你最喜欢的网站和流媒体服务。所以，保护你的数据，从任何地方安全浏览，无需密码，无需职业，当然也无需啤酒桶。访问surfshark.com斜杠TRIH，或者你可以在结账时使用代码TRIH，以获得四个月的额外Surf Shark VPN以及30天退款保证。你好，我是威廉·达林普尔。我是阿尼塔·阿南德，我们是另一个“挂果”节目《帝国》的主持人。
And we are here to tell you about a recent series we've done on Partition. On the 14th and 15th of August, 1947 and India announced their independence from the British Empire. But as these nations gained their freedom, they're rushed and violent. division resulted in the deaths of well over a million people and the forced migration of over 14 million more. It's a piece of South Asian history that many people are familiar with, but in this series we want to explore it alongside four less well-known partitions which continue to affect the region in monumental ways. Yeah, you're quite right. In one episode, we dissect how Dubai almost became part of modern India. And in another, we're going to
我们在这里向大家介绍我们最近制作的关于印巴分治的系列节目。在1947年8月14日和15日，印度宣布脱离大英帝国独立。但是，当这些国家获得自由时，他们仓促而暴力的划分导致了远超一百万人的死亡，以及超过一千万人的被迫流亡。这是许多人熟悉的南亚历史的一部分，但在本系列中，我们希望将其与另外四个不太为人所知的分治事件一同探讨，这些事件继续以巨大的方式影响着该地区。是的，你完全说得对。在其中一集里，我们剖析了迪拜差一点成为现代印度一部分的过程。在另一集里，我们打算
unpack the history behind the headlines about the conflict in Kashmir. We also explore how the separation of Burma from India is linked to the origin of the Rohingya genocide and how East and West Pakistan separated in 1971 to create Bangladesh. So if you'd like to hear more about the five partitions that completely transformed modern Asia and how the weight of the memory of partition has been passed down through the generations, we've left a clip of the series at the end of this episode for you to listen to. Hello, I'm William Durimple. And I'm Anita Arnden, we're the host of another goalhanger show, Empire.
揭开克什米尔冲突头条背后的历史。我们还将探讨缅甸与印度的分离是如何与罗兴亚人种族灭绝的起源联系在一起的，以及东巴基斯坦和西巴基斯坦如何在1971年分离并创建了孟加拉国。因此，如果你想了解更多关于彻底改变现代亚洲的五次分治，以及分治记忆的分量是如何代代相传的，我们在本集节目末尾为你留下了该系列节目的一个片段供你收听。你好，我是威廉·达林普尔。我是阿尼塔·阿南德，我们是另一个“挂果”节目《帝国》的主持人。
And we are here to tell you about a recent series we've done on Partition. On the 14th and 15th of August, 1947 and Pakistan and India announced their independence from the British Empire. But as these nations gained their freedom, their rushed and violent division resulted in the deaths of well over a million people and the forced migration of over 14 million more. It's a piece of South Asian history that many people are familiar with. But in this series, we want to explore it alongside four less well-known partitions, which continue to affect the region in monumental ways. Yeah, you're quite right.
我们在这里向大家介绍我们最近制作的关于印巴分治的系列节目。在1947年8月14日和15日，巴基斯坦和印度宣布脱离大英帝国独立。但是，当这些国家获得自由时，他们仓促而暴力的划分导致了远超一百万人的死亡，以及超过一千万人的被迫流亡。这是许多人熟悉的南亚历史的一部分。但在本系列中，我们希望将其与另外四个不太为人所知的分治事件一同探讨，这些事件继续以巨大的方式影响着该地区。是的，你完全说得对。
In one episode, we dissect how Dubai almost became part of modern India. And in another, we're going to unpack the history behind the headlines about the conflict in Kashmir. We also explore how the separation of Burma from the war. India is linked to the origin of the Rohingya genocide and how eastern West Pakistan separated in 1971 to create Bangladesh. So if you'd like to hear more about the five partitions that completely transformed modern Asia and how the weight of the memory of partition has been passed down through the generations, we've left a clip of the series at the end of this episode for you to listen to.
在其中一集里，我们剖析了迪拜差一点成为现代印度一部分的过程。在另一集里，我们打算揭开克什米尔冲突头条背后的历史。我们还将探讨缅甸与印度的分离是怎么回事。印度与罗兴亚人种族灭绝的起源息息相关，以及东巴基斯坦和西巴基斯坦如何在1971年分离并创建了孟加拉国。因此，如果你想了解更多关于彻底改变现代亚洲的五次分治，以及分治记忆的分量是如何代代相传的，我们在本集节目末尾为你留下了该系列节目的一个片段供你收听。
Hello, welcome back to the rest of history, and this is the second presidential assassination we've done on the show. We've done JFK already. And when we did that, some of our American listeners, I think in particular, complained that you had treated the conspiracy theories with such contempt. Now, I have already suggested for this an excellent conspiracy theory that Ulysses S. Grant, who very suspiciously bailed out of the evening. that Saul Lincoln shot at the theatre that he might have been behind it I've also suggested that maybe Jefferson Davis
你好，欢迎回到“历史的其余部分”，这是我们在节目中做过的第二起总统遇刺案。我们已经讲过肯尼迪了。当我们讲到那个案件时，我记得一些美国听众，尤其是某些听众，抱怨你们对阴谋论的态度充满了轻蔑。现在，我已经为这个案件提出过一个极好的阴谋论，即尤利西斯·S·格兰特，他非常可疑地缺席了当晚的活动。也就是林肯在剧院被枪杀的那天晚上，他可能才是幕后黑手。我还提出也许杰斐逊·戴维斯
was behind it I mean Andrew Johnson the vice president who now becomes president maybe he was behind it so lots of conspiracy theories to deal with here what do you say to them I don't think we need them Tom because we have a conspiracy already
是幕后黑手，我的意思是安德鲁·约翰逊，也就是现在成为总统的副总统，也许他才是幕后黑手，所以这里有大量的阴谋论需要处理，你对它们怎么看？汤姆，我觉得我们不需要这些，因为我们已经有一个现成的阴谋了。
there absolutely was a conspiracy in this case and we don't need to put more people in it because we know who was in it but it's kind of more fun to do that I suppose it is I mean to pile people into it But just to deal with the conspiracy that actually existed. So the others definitely didn't exist. No, I don't think they did.
本案绝对是一个阴谋，我们不需要把更多的人牵扯进来，因为我们知道谁参与其中了，不过这么做似乎更有趣一点。我想是的，我的意思是把很多人都扯进来。但我们还是只处理实际存在的阴谋吧。所以其他人肯定是不存在的。不，我想他们确实不存在。
I think the one possibility is that there were more people who knew about it in the sort of... Confederacy. In the Confederacy. Because there is a link to kind of the Confederate Secret Service in Washington, isn't that? There's a sort of underworld of Confederate sympathizers and agents. And as we will see, they do help the conspirators. So definitely there is a little network. How far it goes, it's hard to say.
我认为有一种可能是，在某种……邦联内部，有更多的人知道这件事。在邦联内部。因为这与华盛顿的邦联特工网有某种联系，对吧？那里有一个由邦联同情者和特工组成的地下世界。正如我们将会看到的，他们确实帮助了阴谋分子。所以绝对存在一个小网络。至于它的规模有多大，很难说。
The plan, as I've said, was to decapitate the American government. Now, it didn't work out quite as John Wilkes Booth had hoped. So one bloke, George Azarot, who was the German repairman, he was supposed to kill Vice President Johnson. He went to Johnson's hotel. He thought he'd have a quick drink to stiffen his nerves. And then he just thought, actually, sod it, I'll just stay in the bar. He completely loses his nerve. He dispensed the evening drinking in the bar.
正如我所说，这个计划是要斩首美国政府。现在，事情的发展并不完全像约翰·威尔克斯·布斯所希望的那样。所以有一个家伙，乔治·阿泽罗特，那个德国修配工，他本该刺杀副总统约翰逊。他去了约翰逊的酒店。他觉得自己应该喝上一小杯来壮壮胆。然后他脑子里一转，其实算了，我还是留在酒吧里吧。他彻底吓破了胆。他把整个晚上都在酒吧里喝酒打发掉了。
And then he wanders the streets. He tries to throw his knife away. He's spotted by a woman throwing a knife down the drain or something. and a few days later he's arrested. Now the other bit of the conspiracy was much more successful. This was the Maryland pharmacist assistant David Herald and the Confederate secret agent Louis Powell. They went to Lafayette Square,
然后他在街上游荡。他试图把自己的刀扔掉。他被一个女人发现把刀扔进下水道还是什么地方了。几天后他被捕了。现在，阴谋的另一部分要成功得多。这就是马里兰州的药剂师助手大卫·赫罗尔德和邦联特工刘易斯·鲍威尔。他们去了拉斐特广场，
which is the House of Secretary of State William Seward. Seward had had a carriage accident and he's recovering in bed. Lewis Powell manages to bluff his way inside. He says to the staff, I'm bringing medicine for Seward from his personal doctor. He goes up to his bedroom, he pulls out his knife, He slashes at Seward's neck, but Seward is partly protected because he's wearing a kind of neck brace,
也就是国务卿威廉·西沃德的宅邸。西沃德遭遇了一场马车事故，正在床上休养。刘易斯·鲍威尔设法虚张声势地混了进去。他对工作人员说，我是来给西沃德送私人医生的药的。他走到卧室，掏出刀，向西沃德的脖子猛砍，但西沃德受到了一定的保护，因为他戴着某种颈托，
sort of splint arrangement, because of his carriage accident. So he's protected from the knife wound. There's then an awful lot of scuffling. And stabbing, I gather, because again, I was just looking at this in the break. Yeah. Apparently he stabs five people. Exactly, exactly. He's just stab, stab, stab, stab.
某种夹板装置，因为他的马车事故。所以他免受了刀伤。接着是一场非常激烈的扭打。据我所知还有捅刺，因为同样地，我在中场休息时刚好查了这个。对的。显然他刺了五个人。没错，没错。他就是捅、捅、捅、捅。
More people are piling into the room, and this by Powell is like scuffling his way down, back down the stairs. He manages to get out of the house and he leaves the house with the excellent phrase. He's shouting, I'm mad. I'm mad. And do you think he is? No, but I think it works because he does get out of the house. Oh, that's why he's saying it. It's not a confession. No, I don't think so. Have you ever read that story about, I don't know whether they can repeat this on the show? Anthony Burgess, you know, Anthony Burgess. Yeah, the novelist. Once said to Kingsley Amis, are you not worried about being attacked in London by ruffians, by muggers? And King's Liam has said, no, and Birch has said, well, I've got a brilliant plan. If ever I'm
更多的人涌进房间，而鲍威尔则是一边扭打一边退回楼梯。他设法逃出了房子，并留下了一句绝妙的名句。他大喊着，我疯了。我疯了。你觉得他当时是疯了吗？不，但我觉得这招管用，因为他确实逃出了房子。哦，这就是他这么喊的原因。这不是自白。不，我不这么认为。你读过那个故事吗，我不知道他们能不能在节目里重复这个？安东尼·伯吉斯，你知道安东尼·伯吉斯吧。是的，那个小说家。曾对金斯利·埃米斯说，你难道不担心在伦敦被暴徒或抢劫犯袭击吗？金斯利·埃米斯说，不担心。伯吉斯说，嗯，我有一个绝妙的计划。如果我被
attacked by muggers. I think about this all the time. He said, I carry a sword stick with me. And if anyone approaches me in the street, I draw the sword stick. And I shout at people, I've got cancer. Goodness, I should try that when I walk down Britson Hill. Exactly. You should. Yeah, I do that all the time. Right. So anyway, Lewis Pals got out, shouting I'm mad, and he lurks around the city in a very ill-advised way. I think it's fair to say, and was arrested on the evening the 17th, so just a few days later. Now, all three of these men were convicted and hanged, as was Mary Surratt, the woman who ran
暴徒袭击的话。我无时无刻不在想这件事。他说，我随身携带一把剑杖。如果有人在街上接近我，我就拔出剑杖。然后我向人们大喊，我得癌症了。天哪，我走在布里克斯顿山时应该试试这个。没错。你应该试试。是的，我经常这么做。好吧。总之，刘易斯·鲍威尔逃出来了，大喊着我疯了，然后他在城里以一种非常不明智的方式鬼鬼祟祟地晃悠。我认为可以这么说，并在17号晚上被捕了，也就是几天之后。现在，这三名男子都被判刑并绞死了，玛丽·苏拉特也是，那个女人经营着
the Confederate safe house in Washington. And she's apparently the first woman to be executed in American history. Really? Apparently so. What have they been doing for all those previous decades? Why had they not executed more women? So women had been incredibly well behaved until that point. Yeah.
华盛顿的邦联安全屋。她显然是美国历史上第一个被处决的女性。真的吗？显然是的。他们在前面那几十年里都在干什么？为什么他们没有处决更多的女性？所以在那之前，女性表现得好得难以置信。是的。
Or dealt with very softly. Yeah, dealt with very softly. Right. Well, John Wilkes' booth is not hanged, unlike this woman. So what happened to him? As you said earlier, there's obviously no doubt that he's Lincoln's killer. He's shot him in full view of all these people and then jumped onto the stage. Many of these people actually know him by sight. Right away, therefore, the police are looking for him. They know he almost certainly will have gone south because any sane person would have tried to cross the Potomac River into Virginia and then to go south in Virginia and to get pass the union lines into the Confederacy. But that's where he obviously goes wrong, isn't it? He should have headed for Canada, because that's the last thing his pursuers would have expected him to do. That's true.
或者对她们的处理非常温和。是的，处理得非常温和。好吧，约翰·威尔克斯·布斯没有被绞死，不像这个女人。那么他发生了什么？正如你刚才所说，毫无疑问他就是林肯的凶手。他在所有这些人的众目睽睽之下枪杀了他，然后跳上了舞台。许多人其实一眼就能认出他。因此，警察立刻开始搜捕他。他们知道他几乎肯定会去南方，因为任何理智的人都会试图穿过波托马克河进入弗吉尼亚，然后经由弗吉尼亚南下，穿过联邦军队的防线进入邦联。但这就是他明显犯错的地方，不是吗？他本该朝加拿大逃去，因为那是他的追捕者做梦也想不到他会去的地方。确实如此。
Head to like the home of abolitionism, Massachusetts or something. Yeah. That would surprise people. Anyway, even before midnight and the night of Lincoln's assassination, the Union Army commanders have sent orders to mobilize troops around the city to seal off the roads, leading south, intercept river traffic and so on. The Secretary of War, Stanton, sends
华盛顿的邦联安全屋。她显然是美国历史上第一个被处决的女人。真的吗？显然是的。那他们在此前的几十年来都在干什么？为什么他们没有处决更多的女性呢？所以女性在此之前一直表现得极其乖巧。是的。
dispatch to the newspapers and he sends instructions to the front lines. Don't let anybody pass through the front lines of Virginia. They produce wanted posters. You can see them online. The price on Booth's head was $100,000. An astronomical amount of money in those days. Let the stain of innocent blood be removed from the land by the arrest and punishment of the murderers, all this kind of thing. But the days go by and there is no sign of him. So what has happened to him? Well, we actually know what happened. to him. They don't know, but we know. When Booth had left the stage, he had gone down this unlit passage that led to the back door of the theatre. Of course, he knew the theatre really well,
向各大报纸发报，并向战线发送指令。不要让任何人通过弗吉尼亚前线。他们制作了通缉令。你可以在网上看到它们。对布斯首级悬赏十万美元。在当时这是一笔天文数字般的巨额资金。让无辜鲜血的污点通过对凶手的逮捕和惩罚从这片土地上洗刷掉，诸如此类的话。但日子一天天过去，依然没有他的踪迹。那么他发生了什么事？好吧，我们其实知道他发生了什么。他们不知道，但我们知道。当布斯离开舞台时，他走进了那条通往剧院后门的未点灯的通道。当然，他非常熟悉这家剧院，
so he knows where he was going. Now, remember I said before that he had rented this mare, and the mare, this horse, is waiting for him in the alley behind the theatre. And Dominic also, in the previous episode, we mentioned how some really top American names will be featuring in the second episode. Yeah. And listeners should prepare themselves for what is to come. Yeah. Booth, before going to the theatre, he approached a stage carpenter
所以他知道自己要去哪里。现在，还记得我之前说过他租了这匹母马吗，这匹母马，这匹马，正在剧院后面的小巷里等他。而且多米尼克在上一集中也提到过，一些美国顶尖的大人物将在第二集里登场。是的。听众们应该为即将发生的事情做好准备。是的。布斯在去剧院之前，找到了一名舞台木工
called Ned Spangler and said, But there's better. Could you hold my fare for me? And Spangler said, all right. And then as soon as Booth was out of sight, Spangler didn't want her to get rid of this horse, and he gave the horse to a junior person at the theatre called Peanut Borrows.
名叫内德·斯潘格勒，并说，不过还有更好的。你能帮我照看一下我的马吗？斯潘格勒说，行吧。然后，一等布斯消失在视线中，斯潘格勒就不想管这匹马了，他把马交给了剧院里一个叫花生·伯勒斯的低年资员工。
So Peanut Borrows is now looking after this horse. Anyway, Booth bursts out of the back door of the theatre, sort of out of the fire exit. The horse is waiting and is startled and tries to kind of pull away, but Booth manages to kind of clamber into the saddle anyway. And it's a very sort of cinematic moment,
所以现在是花生·伯勒斯在照看这匹马。不管怎样，布斯从剧院后门冲了出来，有点像从消防通道冲出来。马在等待着，受到惊吓并试图挣脱，但布斯无论如何还是设法爬上了马鞍。这是一个非常具有电影感的时刻，
just as the first pursuers are coming out of the door behind him, he spurs the horse and rides off down this alley into the darkness. And he clearly traveled very quickly because by about 11.30, he has reached the wooden drawbridge across the Anacostia River,
就在第一批追捕者从他身后的门里出来时，他夹紧马鞍，沿着这条小巷骑马冲入黑暗中。他显然行进得非常快，因为在大约11点30分，他已经到达了横跨阿纳科斯蒂亚河的木制吊桥，
which is by the U.S. Naval Yard. The bridge was guarded by Union, troops. Now, under wartime regulations, because remember, one of the really remarkable things about the American Civil War is that the Union capital, Washington, is effectively a frontline city. So because of the wartime regulations, there was a curfew and you couldn't enter or leave the city after 9 o'clock at night. So Booth turns up at 1140, and a guy called Sergeant Silas Cobb is called out and is told there's a rider trying to get across the bridge. and Booth gives his name. He says my name is Booth. I live in Charles County, Maryland,
该桥位于美国海军造船厂附近。这座桥由联邦军队把守。现在，根据战时条例——因为记住，美国内战的一个非常显著的特点是，联邦首都华盛顿实际上是一个前线城市。因此，根据战时条例，有宵禁规定，晚上9点以后你不能进出这座城市。所以布斯在11点40分出现，一个叫塞拉斯·科布中士的人被叫出来，并被告知有一个骑马的人正试图过桥。布斯报上了他的名字。他说我的名字叫布斯。我住在马里兰州查尔斯县，
and I want to go across the bridge home. And Cobb says, what about the curfew? Do you know about the curfew? And by this point, there isn't a kind of telegraph or anything. So they haven't been notified. No, they haven't been notified, exactly. And Booth says, oh, I didn't know about the curfew. I haven't been into town for ages. So I didn't know about it. Now, Sergeant Cobb hesitates. He finds it weird that the horse has been ridden very hard. So you were asking, Could Booth run with his fractured leg? Not only can he run, he can gallop. He has ridden the horse hard,
我想过桥回家。科布说，宵禁怎么办？你知道宵禁的事吗？而此时，并没有电报之类的东西。所以他们还没有得到通知。不，他们没有得到通知，完全如此。布斯说，哦，我不知道宵禁的事。我好久没进城了。所以我不知道。现在，科布中士犹豫了。他觉得这匹马被骑得很凶这件事很诡异。所以你之前问，布斯带着骨折的腿能跑吗？他不仅能跑，他还能策马疾驰。他把马骑得很急，
but he's struck by the fact that Booth is very well turned out. He actually comments on his nicely sort of quaffed hair and his manicured nails. His pomaded moustache. Exactly. And so Cobb says, well, this guy's obviously, you know, he wouldn't lie. And he says, all right, fine, go across, but you have to walk your horse across the bridge, which Booth does. A few moments later, a second horseman arrives.
但他对布斯打扮得非常体面这一事实印象深刻。他实际上评论了布斯修剪得很好的头发和修整过的指甲。他那涂了发油的小胡子。完全如此。所以科布说，好吧，这家伙显然，你知道的，他不会说谎。然后他说，好吧，行，过去吧，但你必须让你的马步行过桥，布斯照做了。片刻之后，第二个骑马的人到了。
This is Booth's co-conspirator, the pharmacist bloke, David Herald. And he says, I'm going home to Charles County, funnily enough, as well. And Cobb at this point thinks this is kind of peculiar. And he says to this bloke, well, why didn't you leave earlier? And Herald says, you know, there's been a lot of parties in the city. I stopped to see a woman on Capitol Hill, and I couldn't get off before.
这就是布斯的同谋，那个药剂师家伙，大卫·赫罗尔德。他说，真巧，我也要回查尔斯县。科布这时候觉得这有点奇怪。他对这家伙说，好吧，你为什么不早点离开？赫罗尔德说，你知道的，城里有很多派对。我在国会山停下来看一个女人，脱不开身。
And the sergeant thinks, actually, do you know what that is quite plausible? You know, everyone's having a party. He might have shacked up with some woman. And you're not going to make it up. And also, the war's kind of over. Now, who cares? Lee has been beaten. So it doesn't really matter. And so he lets them go and so by midnight,
这位中士心想，其实，你知道吗，这还挺合理的？你知道的，每个人都在聚会。他可能跟哪个女人鬼混去了。而且你总不能编造这个吧。再说了，战争差不多也结束了。现在谁在乎呢？李将军已经被击败了。所以这其实没关系。于是他让他们过去了，因此到了午夜，
both of them across the Anacostia River and they're heading into southern Maryland. Now, the first place they head for is the tavern owned by this Confederate agent or suspected Confederate agent, Mary Surat. And it's in the village of Sarattsville, which is, I believe, since been renamed Clinton
他们两个都穿过了阿纳科斯蒂亚河，正朝马里兰州南部前进。现在，他们前往的第一个地方是这家由邦联特工或疑似邦联特工玛丽·苏拉特拥有的酒馆。它位于苏拉特斯维尔村，据我所知，该村后来被改名为克林顿，
because they didn't want to name it after Confederate traitors. Now remember, Booth had given her a package earlier that day and now he picks it up from the tavern and it contains some binoculars and two carbines, rifles. This is very Lee Harvey Oswald, isn't it? Yeah, it is. People are always carrying curtain rods in American assassination. They love it.
因为他们不想用邦联叛徒的名字来命名。现在记住，布斯那天早些时候曾交给她一个包裹，现在他从酒馆里把它取出来，里面有一些双筒望远镜和两支卡宾枪，也就是步枪。这太像李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德了，不是吗？是的，确实如此。在谋杀美国总统时，人们总是带着窗帘杆。他们太喜欢了。
They love it. Ridiculous names and brown paper packages that could be rifles. Now, the thing about Booth's leg, his leg is now causing him in great pain. and about 4 o'clock in the morning he goes to call on a local doctor called Samuel Mudd, of course he is, who's a keen Confederate supporter
他们太喜欢了。荒谬的名字和可能是步枪的牛皮纸包裹。现在，关于布斯的腿，他的腿现在正给他带来剧烈的疼痛，大约在凌晨4点，他去拜访一位名叫塞缪尔·马德的当地医生——当然他叫这个名字——后者是坚定的邦联支持者，
and was part of his kidnapping scheme. And Mudd says, oh my goodness, you fractured your calf bone. And he makes a splint and he gets them some crutches. And he says, you two, like Booth and Herald, can sleep in my house. Now the next day is Saturday, Mud gets up and he goes and does some errands
也是他绑架计划的一部分。马德说，哦天哪，你的小腿骨折了。他做了一个夹板，并给他们找了一些拐杖。他说，你们俩，也就是布斯和赫罗尔德，可以睡在我家里。第二天是星期六，马德起床去办一些零星杂务，
and he hears in the town or the village. Abraham Lincoln has been murdered. And he obviously puts two and two together. He comes back to the house and he says, you guys have got to go. Like, I can't have you here any longer. They set off through the countryside. Remember that Booth is kind of limping
他在镇上或村里听到亚伯拉罕·林肯被谋杀了。他显然把两件事联系到了一起。他回到房子里说，你们这些家伙得走了。听着，我不能再留你们在这里了。他们穿过乡村出发。记住，布斯一直在瘸着走，
and on crutches part of the time. And he's still got his opera cloak on. Yeah, he's still dressed as the fancy with the opera. They get lost in a swamp and they end up having to beg, ironically, a freed black man called Oswald Swan to help them and guide them through this. swamp and they pay him $12 to guide them to a plantation house owned by another Confederate
而且有时还要靠拐杖。他身上还穿着他的歌剧斗篷。是的，他仍然穿着那身带歌剧披风的花哨衣服。他们在沼泽里迷路了，最后不得不讽刺地哀求一个名叫奥斯瓦尔德·斯旺的被解放的黑人来帮助他们并引导他们穿过这片沼泽，他们付给他12美元让他带他们去一个种植园住宅，该住宅属于另一个他们认识的邦联，
bloat that they know. And there this bloke who owns the plantation gets his overseer to take them to a pine thicket in the swamp. Has there been a film about this? Surely, I think there's been a series, a Netflix series or something of that kind. I must watch it. But there should clearly be another one, a better one, because this is a great story. So they hide in this pine thicket and basically their friends and Confederate agents are trying to figure out how to get and across the Potomac River into Virginia. So they wait in this thicket for about four days and nights, I think. And a local Confederate agent called Thomas Jones pitches up every now and again with food,
家伙。在那里，这个拥有种植园的家伙让他的工头带他们去沼泽里的松树灌木丛。有没有拍过关于这事的电影？当然有，我想有过一个系列剧，一个网飞剧集或者类似的东西。我必须看一看。但显然应该再拍一部更好的，因为这是一个极好的故事。所以他们藏在这个松树灌木丛里，基本上他们的朋友和邦联特工正试图想方设法让他们穿过波托马克河进入弗吉尼亚。所以他们在灌木丛里等了大约四天四夜，我想。一个名叫托马斯·琼斯的当地邦联特工每隔一段时间就会带着食物出现，
and in particular with newspapers. So Booth has not been able to, you know, like any good actor, he's obsessed with his reviews. He wants to read what people have written about him in the papers. And he had written a letter to the newspapers explaining his reasons that he was the American Brutus. And he's absolutely furious that they haven't printed it. They haven't given him the airtime, as it were. And it's at this point that he writes his first journal entry. So this is not the one that you read.
特别是带着报纸。所以布斯一直未能——你知道的，就像任何优秀的演员一样，他对自己的评论有强烈的执念。他想读读人们在报纸上对他的评价。他曾给各大报纸写过一封信，解释他这样做的原因，称自己是美国的布鲁图斯。而报纸没有把信印出来，他对此愤怒至极。他们可以说是没有给他出场时间。正是在这个时候，他写下了他的第一篇日记。所以这不是你读的那篇。
It's an earlier one. And he explains, you know, why he did what he did. He said, our cause being lost, something decisive and great must be done. But its failure was owing to others who did not strike for their country with a heart. I struck boldly and not, as the papers say. So he's already defending himself against the critics. I walked with a firm step through a thousand of his friends. Now, here's an interesting thing.
这是一篇较早的。他解释了（你知道的）他为什么要这样做。他说，既然我们的事业失败了，就必须采取果断和伟大的行动。但它的失败归咎于其他人，他们没有全心全意地为国家奋起打击。我是果断地出击，而不是像报纸上说的那样。所以他已经在为自己辩护以对抗评论家了。我以坚定的步伐走过成千上万他的朋友。现在，这里有一件有趣的事。
I shouted six semper before I fired. Not afterwards. Every other account says he shouted six semper to Iranis after he fired. So do you think his memory is paying tricks on him? Possibly his memory is paying tricks on him. Yeah, exactly. In jumping, I broke my leg. I passed all his pickets.
我在开枪前大喊了“弗吉尼亚人总是这样”（Sic Semper）。不是在开枪后。其他所有的说法都说他在开枪后才大喊“弗吉尼亚人总是这样”。所以你认为他的记忆在和自己开玩笑吗？可能他的记忆在和他开玩笑。是的，绝对如此。在跳跃时，我摔断了腿。我闯过了他所有的哨卡。
I rode 60 miles that night with the bone of my leg tearing the flesh at every jump. I can never repent it. Our country owed all her trouble to him and God simply made me the instrument of his punishment. There is a definite air of sort of hysteria, I think, about this entry. He's not thinking terribly clearly, I think it's fair to say. Thursday the 20th, Thomas Jones is the Confederate agent.
那天晚上我骑马行走了60英里，每一次跳跃，断骨都在撕裂着我的血肉。我绝不后悔。我们国家所有的麻烦都归咎于他，上帝只是让我成为了对他进行惩罚的工具。我认为，这篇日记有一种明显的歇斯底里气氛。我认为公平地说，他当时的想法并不是十分清醒。20日星期四，托马斯·琼斯是邦联特工。
His reports that Union troops are now scouring the woods in a nearby county and he tells them they have to move. They have to go across the river. He's got a fishing boat down on the Potomac. and he pushes them off into the night on this fishing boat it's very foggy
他报告说，联邦军队现在正在附近一个县的树林里搜寻，并告诉他们必须转移。他们必须过河。他在波托马克河上有一艘渔船，他在夜色中把他们推上了这艘渔船，当时雾非常大，
and the Potomac at this point is very wide and they get completely lost they row all lights and then they land and then when they come they realize they're basically
而且波托马克河到这里非常宽，他们彻底迷路了。他们划着船，所有的灯都熄灭了，然后他们靠岸了，接着当他们到达时，他们意识到自己基本上
back where they started but further away and they're still on the wrong side of the river so the next night Friday the 21st Saturday the 22nd they have another go
又回到了出发的地方，只是更远了，而且他们仍然在河的错误一侧。所以第二天晚上，21日星期五，22日星期六，他们又试了一次，
and they manage to row across this time and they land of course they land somewhere called Gambo Creek In the meantime, this is when Booth has written that second journal entry that you read so splendidly. So the tone here, I think, you did it in a very, a bullion style.
这次他们设法划了过去，当然他们在一个叫甘博克reek（Gambo Creek）的地方登陆了。与此同时，这就是布斯写下你刚才朗诵得极其精彩的那第二篇日记的时候。所以我认为这里的基调，你是用一种非常激昂的风格来读的。
Brian Blessed style. I think it's fair to say. But actually, I think he's very bedraggled and miserable at this point. All this stuff about being hunted by like a dog and all this. So I didn't think through what his motivation was. Yeah. It wasn't method acting. No.
布赖恩·布莱瑟（Brian Blessed）式的风格。我认为这样说很公平。但实际上，我认为他此时非常狼狈和悲惨。所有关于像狗一样被追捕之类的话。所以我没有仔细考虑他的动机是什么。是的。这不是体验派表演。不。
Daniel Day Lewis wouldn't approve of that. at all. No, he wouldn't. I should have prepared for it by spending a week being hunted by dogs through brushwood. And then I could have done it justice. Oh, I've let you down, Dominic. I'm really sorry.
丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯绝对不会赞同这一点。不，他不会。我本应该通过花上一周时间在灌木丛中被狗追捕来为这个角色做准备。然后我才能演好它。哦，我让你失望了，多米尼克。我真的很抱歉。
You should have recorded the previous episode, which we've just done, in character, as John Wilkes Booth to prepare you. I should have done. Damn. So anyway, he feels very sorry for himself. I'm abandoned with a curse of cane upon me, when if the world knew my heart, that one blow would have made me great, though I did desire no greatness. And then he says, I have two great a soul to die like a criminal.
你本该在扮演约翰·威尔克斯·布斯的角色时录制我们刚刚完成的上一集，以此来为你做准备。我本该这么做的。该死。不管怎样，他非常顾影自怜。我被遗弃了，身上带着祸根的诅咒，如果世人了解我的内心，那致命的一击本会让我变得伟大，尽管我并不渴望伟大。然后他说，我的灵魂太高尚了，不能像个罪犯一样死去。
He thinks a lot of himself, I think it's fair to say. He does. So for two days, they continue south. On the Sunday night, the 23rd, he lets himself down, behaves very poorly. What do you mean? He lets himself down. He's just shot Abraham Lincoln. That's true.
我觉得他挺自命不凡的，这么说应该挺公允的。他的确是。所以在接下来的两天里，他们继续向南逃。周日晚上，也就是23日，他表现得很差劲，让人大跌眼镜。你这话什么意思？他让人大跌眼镜。他刚刚枪杀亚伯拉罕·林肯。倒也是。
Of course he's let himself down. I think worse of him for this, actually. I think worse of him for this. You see, he arrives at the cabin of a free black family called the Lucases, And he and Herald threatened the father, William Lucas, at knife point, and drive the whole family into the woods so they can sleep in their cabin. That is poor. It is poor. But, I mean, at least he doesn't kill William Lucas.
他当然是让人大跌眼镜。说实话，我对他的看法因此变得更差了。我对他的看法更差了。你看，他来到了一个名叫卢卡斯的自由黑人家庭的小木屋，他和海罗尔德拿着刀威胁父亲威廉·卢卡斯，把全家人赶到树林里，这样他们就能占住木屋睡觉。这行为可真够恶劣的。确实很恶劣。不过，我的意思是，至少他没杀威廉·卢卡斯。
I agree. He's not coming across well from this series. It reflects really badly on him. It reflects really badly. Yeah, I accept that. The next day, Monday the 24th, he and Herald meet three Confederate soldiers who lead them to a tobacco farm, inevitably called Locust Hill. This is the world's most American story. It is.
我同意。从这个系列来看，他的形象不太好。这对他产生了非常负面的影响。影响极其恶劣。是的，我承认这一点。第二天，也就是24日星期一，他和海罗尔德遇到了三名邦联士兵，士兵带他们去了一个烟草农场，很不巧，这个农场叫“蝗虫山”。这是世界上最美国的故事。确实如此。
Locust Hill, and it's owned by a man who actually has a reasonable name, Richard Garrett. That's disappointing. Booth says, I'm a wounded Confederate soldier, and Garrett says, fine, you can stay. Herald actually goes off with his other Confederate soldiers into the nearby town, which is called Bowling Green. So Garrett doesn't say, if you're a Confederate soldier, why are you wearing evening dress? Yeah, why are you dressed like the fancy of the opera? No, he doesn't. Actually, and at first, it's lovely, sweetness and light.
蝗虫山，农场主的名字其实还算正常，叫理查德·加勒特。这倒让人有点失望。布斯说，我是一名受伤的邦联士兵，加勒特说，行，你可以留下来。海罗尔德其实和另外几名邦联士兵一起去了附近一个叫鲍灵格林的小镇。难道加勒特没问，如果你是邦联士兵，为什么穿着晚礼服？对啊，为什么打扮得像是去歌剧院的名流？不，他没问。事实上，起初一切都很美好，一片祥和。
So Booth has a nice rest, he has a nice breakfast, and then he plays with Garrett's children on the lawn. So maybe his leg is a bit better. But then things start to unravel. Herald and the soldiers come back to the Garrett farm, to Locust Hill, and they say there's Union Cavalry in the area. And Booth panics and he rushes off to hide in the woods. And at this point, the Garrett family become very suspicious. If he's just an ordinary Confederate soldier, you know, why would he have panicked and run away to the woods? The war's kind of over, you know, there's very low risk, strange behaviour. When he finally emerges, they say, are you really in the Confederate army?
于是布斯好好休息了一番，吃了一顿丰盛的早餐，然后还在草坪上和加勒特的孩子们玩耍。所以也许他的腿好点了吧。但接着事情开始露馅了。海罗尔德和士兵们回到了加勒特农场，也就是蝗虫山，他们说附近有联邦骑兵。布斯顿时惊慌失措，急忙逃进树林里躲藏起来。就在这时，加勒特一家人生疑了。如果他只是一个普通的邦联士兵，你知道的，他为什么要惊慌失措地逃进树林呢？战争基本上已经结束了，你知道的，风险很低，这行为太奇怪了。当他终于出来时，他们问，你真的是邦联军队的吗？
He says, oh yeah, I was in, this is where his acting skills come in. He says, I was in Captain Robinson's company of the 30th Virginia. But as luck would have it, Richard Garrett's son, Jack, is a Confederate soldier. And he knows that unit. And he knows there is no such captain. So they have a massive argument. And the Garrets eventually say, right, Okay, you guys can stay one more night.
他说，哦，是的，我加入过——这就是他演技派本色发挥作用的时候了。他说，我在弗吉尼亚第30团罗宾逊上尉的连队。但很不巧的是，理查德·加勒特的儿子杰克是一名邦联士兵。他熟悉这个连队。而且他知道根本没有什么罗宾逊上尉。于是他们发生了激烈的争吵。加勒特一家最后说，好吧，你们可以再住一晚。
We're not going to have you in the house. You can stay in the tobacco barn. But the Garrets now think that these blokes are probably horse thieves, so they lock the barn door once Booth and Herald are inside. Now, meanwhile, in the nearby town... What's the nearby town called, Dominic? Bowling Green. It's unbelievable.
我们不准你们住在屋里。你们可以住在烟草谷仓里。但加勒特现在觉得这两个家伙可能是偷马贼，所以等布斯和海罗尔德进去后，他们把谷仓门给锁上了。现在，与此同时，在附近的小镇上……附近的镇叫什么名字，多米尼克？鲍灵格林。这太难以置信了。
Officers of the National Detective Police and a detachment of the 16th New York Cavalry have arrived to her. hunt for the fugitives, and they talked to these three Confederate soldiers who had helped Booth and Herald, and basically get the truth out of them. It takes them two hours to ride to Locust Hill Farm, and they arrive at about two in the morning. They surround the house, they drag the Garrets out of bed, and they basically say to Richard Garrett, if you don't tell us where these guys are, we will hang you, right here.
国家侦探警察局的官员和纽约骑兵第16分队的 detachment 已经赶到了这里搜捕逃犯，他们与那三名曾帮助过布斯和海罗尔德的邦联士兵交谈，基本上从他们口中套出了实情。他们骑马花了两个小时才到达蝗虫山农场，大约凌晨两点到达。他们包围了房子，把加勒特一家从床上拖起来，基本上对理查德·加勒特说，如果你不告诉我们这些人在哪，我们就在这儿吊死你。
Jack Garrett, this Confederate soldier, who's still wearing his Confederate uniform, comes out, and he says, Father, just tell them. so they go to the barn and the detectives send Jack Garrett to speak to the fugitives say come out they won't come out then the chief of the detectives who's called Luther Byron Baker
杰克·加勒特，这个依然穿着邦联制服的邦联士兵走了出来，他说，父亲，告诉他们吧。于是他们去了谷仓，侦探们派杰克·加勒特去跟逃犯对话，说出来吧，他们不肯出来。接着，这位名叫路德·拜伦·贝克的侦探长官
he shouts into the barn he says surrender come out and if you don't come out I'll burn this barn down you've got 15 minutes Harold wants to give up Booth says no no don't give up don't give up whispering to him
冲着谷仓大喊，他说投降吧，出来，如果不出来我就把这谷仓烧了。你们有15分钟时间。海罗尔德想投降。布斯说不，不，别投降，别投降，在一旁低声对他说。
Luther Byron Baker says I'm going to start burning this barn down and Booth shouts back He says, Captain, that's rather rough. I'm nothing but a cripple. I have but one leg. You ought to give me a chance for a fair fight. And Baker says, listen, you've got five minutes
路德·拜伦·贝克说我可要开始烧这谷仓了。布斯在里面回喊道。他说，长官，这也太粗暴了。我不过是个残疾人。我只有一条腿。你该给我一个公平决斗的机会。贝克说，听着，你们还有五分钟时间
and I'm going to burn this bloody barn down. Booth is playing for time, making all sort of complaints and stuff, and eventually they pile brushwood against the barn, and one of them sets a delight. At this point, Herald panics. He runs to the door. Let me out, let me out. He manages to get out, and the troopers grab him and tie him up.
我就要把这个该死的谷仓烧了。布斯在拖延时间，各种抱怨个不停，最后他们把刷状的杂柴堆在谷仓旁，其中一人点燃了火。就在这时，海罗尔德慌了神。他跑向门边。放我出去，放我出去。他设法逃了出来，骑兵们一把抓住他并把他捆了起来。
So now there's just Booth. And Booth, remember, has a rifle. He has one of his rifles from the tavern. The fire is spreading now across the barn. It spreads to the rafters. The barn is lit up with this weird glow. And through the cracks in the timbers, the soldiers can see both. As Michael Kaufman says in his book,
所以现在只剩下布斯了。大家记住，布斯手里有一支步枪。他有从酒馆带出来的那支步枪。大火现在正蔓延过整个谷仓。火势蔓延到了椽子上。谷仓被这种诡异的光芒照亮了。透过木板的缝隙，士兵们可以看到布斯。正如迈克尔·考夫曼在他的书中所说的那样
he's trapped like a wild animal kind of darting around looking for a place to escape. And Dominic, it is at this point that the moment long-term fans of the rest of his history have been looking forward to. Yeah. Because it is now that one of history's top 10 eunuchs makes his appearance in this series. Yes, Sergeant Boston Corbett. Which you would say is in a, I mean, it's a classic American name, but actually is English. He's a Londoner. The distinctive thing about Boston Corbett, so he's a trooper there with the cavalry, is that he is literally as mad as a hatter.
他就像一头野兽一样被困住，东奔西突地寻找逃生的地方。多米尼克，正是在这个时候，他的历史节目的长期粉丝们一直期待的时刻来到了。是的。因为正是在这个时候，历史上的十大太监之一在这个系列中登场了。是的，波士顿·科比特中士。你会说这是一个典型的美国名字，但实际上它是英国的。他是伦敦人。波士顿·科比特与众不同的地方——他是骑兵队的一名骑兵——在于他简直疯得像个帽匠。
Because he is a hatter, right? He had worked as a milliner in New York, and he'd been driven mad by the mercury. I think they used mercury for fur, didn't they? Yes. To cure the fur in hats. We did an episode on that. Yeah. And he became a religious maniac, that is to say, a Methodist.
因为他本来就是个帽匠，对吧？他曾在纽约当过女帽匠，结果被水银弄得精神失常。我想他们当时用水银来处理皮草吧？是的。用来处理帽子上的皮草。我们做过一期关于这个的节目。是的。然后他成了一个宗教狂热分子，也就是说，成了一个循道宗信徒。
Apologies to any Methodist listeners for Dominic's abuse. While pursuing his Methodism in Boston, Massachusetts, he castrated himself with a pair of scissors, didn't he? He did. It's a whole scissors theme actually in our show because you remember Charles the 12th of Sweden cut his own foot open with some scissors but this is much more extreme he unmanned himself with these scissors
向所有收听节目的循道宗听众为多米尼克的冒犯道歉。在马萨诸塞州波士顿追求他的循道宗信仰时，他用一把剪刀阉割了自己，对吧？他是这么干的。我们节目里其实有个剪刀的主题，因为大家还记得瑞典的查理十二世用剪刀划开过自己的脚，但这要极端得多，他用剪刀自己阉割了自己。
then he enlisted in the Union Army became a prisoner of war at Andersonville Prison great sort of notorious Confederate prison and then he was exchanged just in time to serve in the detachment sent to capture booth So Boston Corbett is looking through the cracks in the timbers and he sees Booth raise his rifle and move towards the door. Now almost certainly Booth was surrendering, was planning to surrender, I think.
然后他加入了联邦军队，在臭名昭著的邦联安德森维尔战俘营成了战俘，接着他刚好赶上交换俘虏，得以在抓捕布斯的搜捕分队中服役。所以波士顿·科比特正透过木板的缝隙向里张望，他看到布斯举起步枪向门口走去。现在几乎可以肯定，布斯当时是在投降，正打算投降，我是这么认为的。
Their barn is on fire. Boston Corbett just fired. He fired through the gaps in the timbers, his revolver, and Booth is down. And Dominic, there's never been any kind of notion that he's a kind of Jack Ruby figure. employed to silence him. Working for Mrs. Ulysses S. Grant. That's not part of conspiracy theory law. I think only by you, Tom.
他们的谷仓着火了。波士顿·科比特开枪了。他透过木板缝隙用左轮手枪开了枪，布斯应声倒地。多米尼克，从来没有任何说法认为他是什么杰克·鲁比式的人物。被雇来灭口的。为尤利西斯·S·格兰特夫人效力的。这可不在阴谋论的范畴内。我想只有你这么认为，汤姆。
Yeah, I mean, write in if there is a conspiracy theory along that line. This is American history. Therefore, there are almost certainly some mad theories out there, I would imagine. Anyway, maybe that bloke they carry out is not John Wilkes booth. Maybe the real John Wolksbyter is somewhere else. Who knows? Anyway, they carry him out. Boston Corbitts shot him in the neck.
对啊，我是说，如果有这方面的阴谋论，大家可以写信来。这是美国历史。因此，我猜想几乎肯定会有一些疯狂的理论存在。不管怎样，也许他们抬出来的那个家伙根本不是约翰·威尔克斯·布斯。也许真正的约翰·威尔克斯·布斯在别的地方呢？谁知道呢。不管怎样，他们把他抬了出来。波士顿·科比特一枪打中了他的脖子。
the bullet went through his neck and through his spinal column, so he's dying. One of the detectives who has the excellent name, Everton Conger. Everton, Conk. Oh, what is it with these names? There's a eunuch and how does somebody with the name of Conger. Boston Corb in Everton, Conger.
子弹穿过了他的脖子和脊椎骨，所以他快死了。其中一位拥有极妙名字的侦探叫埃弗顿·康格。埃弗顿，康格。哦，这些名字是怎么回事？有个太监，怎么会有人叫康格这个名字。波士顿·科比特和埃弗顿·康格。
There's far too many surnames in those names. That's four people. They could be a crime-fighting duo. The Unica, the Conger. Solving crimes in Reconstruction America. Okay, Everton Congen kneels over him, and Booth whispers, Tell my mother that I did it for my country.
这些名字里的姓氏实在太多了。那是四个人。他们可以组成一个打击犯罪的双人组。乌尼卡、康格。在重建时期的美国解决犯罪问题。好吧，埃弗顿·康根俯身在他身上，布思喃喃道：“告诉我的母亲，我是为了国家才这么做的。”
Tell my mother that I'd die for my country. So he's a mummy's boy right to the end. And it took hours for him to die. He kept repeating that line about his mother and his country. But then as dawn breaks, again, perfect for Hollywood cinematographer, as dawn breaks, he whispers, useless, useless, and then he dies. That's the end of John Mark's Booth.
“告诉我的母亲，我愿为国牺牲。”所以他到死都是个恋母情结的孩子。他花了几个小时才死去。他一直在重复那句关于母亲和国家的话。但随后黎明破晓，再次完美契合了好莱坞摄影师的风格，黎明破晓时，他喃喃自语道：没用，没用，然后他就死了。这就是约翰·威尔克斯·布思的结局。
Now, the thing is, his story is so rich, actually. This book that I mentioned by Michael Kaufman, American Brutus is brilliant. He thinks the key to Booth is that he was an actor, that basically he lived in a world of make-believe, that his identity as a southern gentleman was a complete fiction. He'd never lived in the South properly. He came from a border state. He'd never had a great success in the South.
现在的问题是，他的故事其实非常丰富。我提到的迈克尔·考夫曼写的这本书《美国布鲁图斯》非常精彩。他认为理解布思的关键在于他是一名演员，基本上他生活在一个幻想的世界里，他作为南方绅士的身份完全是个虚构。他从来没有真正真正在南方生活过。他来自一个边境州。他在南方从未取得过巨大的成功。
All his success was in the north. So he's basically a Yankee. Yeah, but he's invented this fantasy life for himself. And as Kaufman says, he constructed a dramatic persona for himself rather than accept the truth that he was a hot-headed loser who only talked while others gave their lives. His title is American Brutus. And of course, the great irony is that John Wilkesbuth dreamt of being Brutus, but it never occurred to him that Brutus was a failure. Yeah. That Brutus turned Caesar into a martyr and that actually his actions hastened the end of the Roman Republic.
他所有的成功都在北方。所以他基本上是个北方佬。是的，但他为自己编造了这种幻想的生活。正如考夫曼所说，他为自己构建了一个戏剧化的人设，而不是接受这样一个事实：他只是一个头脑发热的失败者，只会动嘴皮子，而别人却付出了生命。他的书名叫《美国布鲁图斯》。当然，最大的讽刺在于，约翰·威尔克斯·布思梦想成为布鲁图斯，但他却从未想到布鲁图斯是个失败者。是的。布鲁图斯把恺撒变成了一位烈士，而实际上他的行动加速了罗马共和国的灭亡。
that he destroyed his own cause and of course that's what John Wilkes Booth does to some degree. Now the real question that hangs over all this is, which is a shame to be asking this question after we spent a lot of time on this show did it matter instead of any importance? And of course a lot of American listeners
他亲手毁了自己的事业，当然，约翰·威尔克斯·布思在某种程度上也是这么做的。现在，悬在这一切之上的真正问题是——在节目中花了大量时间探讨这个问题之后再问可能有些遗憾——这真的重要吗，它有什么重要性吗？当然，许多美国听众
will say that it mattered enormously because as with John F. Kennedy, you know, with John F. Kennedy, there is this sort of fantasy. If Kennedy lives, you don't get Vietnam. You don't get the Vietnam War and the sort of darker turn of the late 60s and Nixon and everything that follows. And the fantasy that's so common, if Lincoln's death is, Lincoln lives and the South is beaten, but Lincoln controls reconstruction, black Americans are given the vote,
会说这极其重要，因为正如约翰·F·肯尼迪一样，你知道的，对于约翰·F·肯尼迪，存在着这样一种幻想：如果肯尼迪活着，就不会有越南战争。就不会有越战，也不会有60年代后期那种更黑暗的转向、尼克松以及随之而来的一切。而关于林肯之死，最普遍的幻想是：林肯活下来了，南方被击败了，但由林肯来掌控重建，赋予黑人美国人投票权，
the Confederates never regain control of the southern states, there is no segregation, the Jim Crow laws of the 20th century, that actually all is sweetness and light. And personally, I find this unbelievably unconvincing and implausible. I think first of all, because like the Kennedy sort of fantasies, it massively exaggerates the power of the presidency. What actually happens is Reconstruction ends up being a huge power struggle between the White House and Congress, which Congress actually wins. And Lincoln's successor Andrew Johnson ends up being impeached. So there's a real irony there that Lincoln is murdered for being a tyrant, for being a Caesar. Yeah. But there's actually the problem that he would
南方邦联再也没有夺回南方各州的控制权，没有种族隔离，没有20世纪的吉姆·克劳法，实际上一切都是美好而光明。就我个人而言，我觉得这极其令人难以置信且不合情理。首先我认为，就像关于肯尼迪的种种幻想一样，它极大地夸大了总统的权力。实际情况是，重建最终变成了白宫和国会之间的一场巨大权力斗争，而国会实际上赢了。林肯的继任者安德鲁·约翰逊最终遭到弹劾。这里面有一个真正的讽刺，那就是林肯被谋杀是因为他被视为暴君，被视为恺撒。是的。但实际上他将面临的问题是
have faced is that he's not nearly autocratic enough. Exactly. And that actually, as soon as the war is over, Congress sort of sought to roll back a lot of his, what they saw is his more imperial powers. The second thing, I think the sort of fantasy tributes Lincoln with superhuman political skills that no human being ever possessed. Because Lincoln is a lame duck president and he's already facing massive opposition in Congress. Now, a lot of people expect that from the Democrats who think he's a dictator. But the really interesting thing that I think would surprise a lot of listeners
他的专制程度远远不够。没错。实际上，战争一结束，国会就试图收回他的许多权力，也就是他们眼中更具帝国色彩的权力。第二点，我认为这种幻想把林肯赋予了超越常人的政治技能，这是任何人类都不可能具备的。因为林肯是一位跛脚鸭总统，他已经面临着国会中巨大的反对声音。现在，许多人认为这很正常，来自那些认为他是独裁者的民主党人。但真正有趣、可能会让许多听众感到惊讶的是
is the opposition from radicals in his own party. So this is an extraordinary thing that when he dies, a lot of the keenest abolitionists in the Republican Party are actually delighted. They held a meeting after his death and the Indiana Congressman George Julian recorded, quote, the universal feeling that his death is a godsend.
来自他自己党内激进派的反对。这是一件非同寻常的事：当他去世时，共和党内许多最热心的废奴主义者实际上非常高兴。他在死后举行了一次会议，印第安纳州众议员乔治·朱利安记录道，引述：“普遍的感触是，他的死简直是天赐良机。”
Because many of them think quite wrongly that his vice president will do a better job. But I mean, imagine if you'd had, I don't know, members of the FBI or the CIA meeting up and saying that Kennedy's death was a godsend, you would suspect a conspiracy. You think the radical Republicans killed Abraham Lincoln? The whole thing is just spiraling out of control here.
因为他们中的许多人错误地认为，他的副总统会做得更好。但我的意思是，想象一下，如果联邦调查局或中央情报局的成员聚在一起说肯尼迪的死是天赐良机，你一定会怀疑这是一场阴谋。你会认为是激进的共和党人杀害了亚伯拉罕·林肯吗？这里的局势完全失控了。
I mean, actually, if you want evidence, Tom. So, Zachariah Chandler, Senator from Michigan. God continued Mr. Lincoln in office as long as he was useful and then substituted a better man to finish the work. Benjamin Wade, Senator from Ohio, by the gods, there will be no trouble now in running the government. Mr. Lincoln had too much of human kindness in his deal with his infamous traitors. In other words, the radical Republicans are much,
我的意思是，如果你想要证据的话，汤姆。来自密歇根州的参议员扎卡里亚·钱德勒说：“上帝让林肯先生在位，直到他发挥了作用，然后换了一个更好的人来完成这项工作。”来自俄亥俄州的参议员本杰明·韦德说：“看在上帝的份上，现在管理政府不会再有麻烦了。林肯先生在与那些臭名昭著的叛徒打交道时，表现出过多的人类仁慈。”换句话说，激进的共和党人
less on Lincoln's team than we often think. And they would probably have fallen out with him in the next few months or years over reconstruction. But the biggest thing, actually, the issue of the South and, you know, racism, white supremacy, it can't be fixed by one man. Because it would have taken, I think, a long-term military regime in the southern states committed to black equality to change things. And the North was never, ever going to accept such a political and financial commitment. The White South would always have resisted. There would always have been paramilitary groups like the Ku Klux Klan. And we actually know from Lincoln's public statements, that's the reason I mentioned them in the first episode. He's desperate to get the White
远没有我们通常认为的那般支持林肯。在接下来的几个月或几年里，他们很可能会因为重建问题而与他翻脸。但最重要的事情，实际上是南方的问题和种族主义、白人至上主义，是无法由一个人解决的。因为我认为，这需要南方各州建立长期的、致力于实现黑人平等的军事政权才能改变现状。而北方永远、永远不会接受这样的政治和财政承诺。白人南方人永远会进行抵抗。永远会有像三K党这样的准军事组织。我们实际上从林肯的公开声明中得知，这也是我在第一集里提到他们的原因，他极渴望让白人
South integrated as quickly as possible to return to what he sees as harmony and reconciliation. So the destiny of the United States as a continental power, even to Lincoln, is more significant. than establishing racial equality? Yes, I would say so, actually. Now, I don't say that to diminish him. He's a practical politician. He's choosing from different priorities. I think he is committed to racial equality,
南方人尽快融入，回到他所认为的和谐与和解状态。因此，即使对林肯而言，美国作为大陆强权的命运，也比确立种族平等更重要？是的，我实际上会这么说。现在，我这么说并不是为了贬低他。他是一个务实的政治家。他在不同的优先事项中进行选择。我认为他确实致力于种族平等，
but gradually, and I think he would have found the challenge just as complex and demanding as his successors did, as Ulysses S. Grant did, actually, when he became president. So in a way, you can argue that, as with Kennedy, his killer actually does him a real favor.
但那是渐进式的。我认为他会发现这一挑战和他的继任者一样复杂且苛刻，就像尤利西斯·S·和格兰特当上总统时所面临的那样。所以在某种程度上，可以说正如肯尼迪一样，他的凶手实际上帮了他一个大忙。
You know, John Wilkes Booth turns him into a martyr because there's nothing the world likes more than a kind of slain hero, right? As you implied in the first episode, there's nothing you enjoy more than an idol with feet of clay. Yeah. But what we've just been talking about in the relation to Lincoln, do you think that diminishes him? Does that diminish his reputation or not? Do you think Lincoln deserves the kind of the reputation that he has, not just in America, but really across the world? Yeah, I think he does actually.
你知道，约翰·威尔克斯·布思把他变成了一位烈士，因为世界上没有比被杀害的英雄更让人喜闻乐见的东西了，对吧？正如你在第一集所暗示的那样，没有什么比一个泥足巨人更让人津津乐道了。是的。但是我们刚刚讨论的关于林肯的内容，你认为这会贬低他吗？这会贬低他的声誉吗？你认为林肯是否配得上他在美国乃至全世界所拥有的声誉？是的，我确实认为他配得上。
Michael Burlingame in this book that I've mentioned a few times, brilliant biography. He says Lincoln, you know, had a personality that you very rarely find in politics. Somebody who is firmly committed to a vision, who has the practical, pragmatic skills in order to achieve it, but is a fully kind of realized human being, reflective, humble, thoughtful, with a kind of wry sense of his own place in the grand scheme of things. You know, not without ego, of course, none of us are, but he's able to hold his ego in check. a really impressive person, I would say. I don't know huge amounts about his life, but everything that I read about him, two things strike me. One is that he has this incredible ability that
我提到的这本迈克尔·伯林盖姆写的书中，这是一本精彩的传记。他说林肯拥有你在政坛极难找到的个性。一个坚定致力于某种愿景、具备实现这一愿景的实用和务实技能、同时又是一个完全成熟的人类的人——具有反思力、谦逊、体贴，对自己在宏大计划中的位置有一种苦笑式的清醒认知。你知道，当然也不是没有自我，我们谁都有，但他能克制住自己的自我。可以说是一个非常令人印象深刻的人。我对他的生平了解不多，但关于他的一切读下来，有两点让我印象深刻。第一点是，他拥有那种
all the really great, morally profound American politicians have had. So we did a series on Martin Luther King. Lincoln has this ability to kind of channel a spirit of biblical prophecy and associate it with a brighter future for America. Yeah. But also, he seems to be fun. He's an engaging, amusing person. And that combination of biblical profit and somebody who would be fun to be with, they don't always gel. Let's put it like that.
所有真正伟大、道德深邃的美国政治家都具备的非凡能力。所以我们做过一期关于马丁·路德·金的节目。林肯拥有这种能力，能够引导圣经预言的精神，并将其与美国更光明的未来联系起来。是的。但同时，他似乎很有趣。他是一个迷人、幽默的人。圣经先知般的特质与一个相处起来充满乐趣的人，这两种结合并不总是能完美融洽。这么说吧。
No, you're absolutely right. And actually, you mentioned Daniel Day Lewis. So Tabby, our producer, loves the Lincoln film. And actually persuaded me to watch it a few weeks ago. And Daniel DeLewis does bring this out in the Stephen Spielberg film. There is a kind of whimsy to him, a folksiness. Sometimes folksness can be very annoying, but I think it's not terribly annoying in this film. I think the last word should go to somebody who's one of Lincoln's great contemporaries.
不，你说得完全对。事实上，你提到了丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯。我们的制片人塔比非常喜欢《林肯》这部电影。她实际上在几周前说服我看了这部电影。在史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格的电影中，丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯确实把这一点展现出来了。他身上有一种奇特的异想天开和质朴。有时质朴会非常烦人，但我认为在这部电影里并不是特别烦人。我想把最后的话留给林肯的一位伟大同代人。
Somebody who wasn't American, you know, didn't actually know that much about America, but was undoubtedly a great figure. And that person oddly, I think Michael Burlingham quotes him in his book, is Tolstoy. So for the centenary of Lincoln's birth in 1909, the New York world, sent a reporter to Tolstoy's estate, Yasnaya Poliana to ask Tolstoy, because they said, he's the world's greatest writer. Let's see what he's got to say about Lincoln. And this is what Tolstoy said.
一个不是美国人的人，你知道的，实际上对美国并不那么了解，但无疑是一个伟大的人物。而那个人很奇怪地——我想迈克尔·伯林盖姆在他的书中引用了这句话——就是托尔斯泰。因此，在1909年林肯诞辰百年之际，《纽约世界报》派遣了一名记者前往托尔斯泰位于雅斯纳亚-波利亚纳的庄园去询问托尔斯泰，因为他们说，他是世界上最伟大的作家。让我们看看他对林肯有什么看法。这就是托尔斯泰所说的话。
He said, of all the great national heroes and statesmen of history, Lincoln is the only real giant. Alexander, Frederick the Great, Caesar, Napoleon, Glaston, even Washington. Frankly, I wouldn't put Washington in that list, because you know my views on Washington with other people's teeth in his mouth. Even Washington, they stand in greatness of character in depth and feeling and in certain moral power far behind Lincoln. He came through many hardships and much experience to the realization that the greatest human achievement is love. He was what Beethoven was in music, Dante and poetry, Raphael in painting, and Christ in the philosophy of life. There's your Christ comparison, Tom. Lincoln was a man of whom a nation has a right to be proud.
他说，在历史上所有伟大的民族英雄和政治家中，林肯是唯一的真正巨人。亚历山大、腓特烈大帝、恺撒、拿破仑、格莱斯顿，甚至华盛顿——坦率地说，我不会把华盛顿列入这个名单，因为你知道我对华盛顿的看法，嘴里塞着别人的假牙——甚至华盛顿，他们在性格的伟大、情感的深度和某种道德力量上，都远远落后于林肯。他经历了许多艰难险阻和丰富阅历，最终认识到人类最伟大的成就是爱。他就是音乐领域的贝多芬、诗歌领域的但丁、绘画领域的拉斐尔，以及生活哲学领域的基督。你的基督对比来了，汤姆。林肯是一个让整个民族有权为之骄傲的人。
He was a saint of humanity, whose name will live thousands of years and the legends of future generations. He lived and died a hero, and as a great character, he will live as long as the world lives. What a tone to end on. Thank you, Dominic. That was fascinating. Thank you, everyone, for listening. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
他是人类的圣徒，他的名字将在未来几千年的后代传说中流芳百世。他生为英雄，死为英雄，作为一个伟大的人物，他将与世长存。多么完美的结束语。谢谢你，多米尼克。太精彩了。谢谢大家的收听。再见。再见。
Hi, it's William Drimple here, again from Empire, another Goldhanger podcast. Here's the clip from our recent series on the five partitions that created modern Asia. And it was deeply emotional. Sparsh picked up some pebbles from the village, which he made into jewelry, family heirlooms for his family going down the generations because he was always saying, you know, my family doesn't have archives, etc. We lost everything
嗨，我是威廉·德林普尔，再次来自帝国播客，这是另一个高杭播客。以下是我们最近关于创造现代亚洲的五次分区节目的剪辑。那是极其感人的。斯帕什从村子里捡了一些鹅卵石，把它们做成了首饰，作为传给世世代代子孙的传家宝，因为他总是说，你知道的，我的家族没有档案馆等等。我们失去了一切
in partition and there's nothing that we have from Bela to show where we came from. But so he wanted to pick up something from Bela and make it into airlines for the next generations. You know, three, four generations from now they'll still have a piece of Bela with them, even if you know, the relationship between India
在印巴分治中，我们没有任何东西可以证明我们来自贝拉。但他想从贝拉捡回一些东西，把它做成传给下一代的传家宝。你知道，从今往后的三四代人，他们身上仍然会带着一块贝拉的碎片，哪怕你知道，印度
and Pakistan worsens again. And, you know, even if his kids can never visit Bela, they'll always have a piece of Bela with This connection with earth, dhirti, you know, they call it dhurti in India, and Zamin is the Urdu word, exactly the same thing, but it is much more than just the earth. It is who you are, where you have grown from, where your forebears have grown from. And the number of people I know who have been lucky enough to travel across the border, and I count myself as one, who find it impossible to leave without a scoop of earth, and I have one too. You know, in Lahore,
和巴基斯坦的关系再次恶化。而且，你知道的，即使他的孩子们永远无法访问贝拉，他们也永远会有一块贝拉的……这种与土地的联系，德蒂（dhirti），你知道的，他们在印度叫它德蒂，而扎明（Zamin）是乌尔都语中的词，完全是同一个意思，但它不仅仅是土地。它是你是谁，你从哪里成长起来，你的祖先从哪里成长起来。我知道有很多人有幸跨越边境旅行，我把自己也算在内，他们发现离开时手里没有一把泥土是不可能的，我也有一个。你知道，在拉合尔，
picked up a handful of earth and brought it back with me. because I thought, you know, this is the stuff of my grandfather used to walk on. To hear the full series, just search Empire wherever you get your podcasts. Hi, it's William Drimple here again from Empire, another Goldhanger podcast. Here's the clip from our recent series on the five partitions that created Modern Asia. And it was deeply emotional. Sparsh picked up some pebbles from the village, which he made into jewelry, family heirlooms for his family going down the generations.
抓了一把泥土带了回来。因为我想，你知道的，这就是我祖父曾经走过的那片土地。要收听完整系列，只需在任何获取播客的地方搜索《帝国》。嗨，我是威廉·德林普尔，再次来自帝国播客，这是另一个高杭播客。以下是我们最近关于创造现代亚洲的五次分区节目的剪辑。那是极其感人的。斯帕什从村子里捡了一些鹅卵石，把它们做成了首饰，作为传给世世代代子孙的传家宝。
Because he was always saying, my family doesn't have archives, et cetera. We lost everything in partition. And there's nothing that we have from Baylor to show where we came from. But so he wanted to pick up something from Baylor and make it into heirlooms for the next generations. You know, three, four generations from now,
因为他总是说，我的家族没有档案馆等等。我们在分治中失去了一切。我们没有任何来自贝拉的东西来证明我们来自哪里。但他想从贝拉捡回一些东西，把它做成传给下一代的传家宝。你知道，从今往后的三四代人，
they'll still have a piece of bailer with them, even if, you know, the relationship between India and Pakistan worsens again. And, you know, even if his kids can never visit Baylor, they'll always have a piece of bail with them. This connection with earth, dhirti, you know, they call it dhurti in India, and Zamin is the Udu word for exactly the same thing. But it is much more than just the earth. It is who you are, where you have grown from, where your forebears have grown from. And the number of people I know who have been lucky enough to travel across the border, and I count myself as one, who find it impossible to leave without a scoop of earth.
他们身上仍然会带着一块贝拉的碎片，即使，你知道的，印度和巴基斯坦的关系再次恶化。而且，你知道的，即使他的孩子们永远无法访问贝拉，他们也永远会有一块贝拉的碎片。这种与土地的联系，德蒂（dhirti），你知道的，他们在印度叫它德蒂，而扎明（Zamin）是乌尔都语中的词，完全是同一个意思。但它不仅仅是土地。它是你是谁，你从哪里成长起来，你的祖先从哪里成长起来。我知道有很多人有幸跨越边境旅行，我把自己也算在内，他们发现离开时手里没有一把泥土是不可能的。
And I have one too. You know, in Lahore picked up a handful of earth and brought it back with me. because I thought, you know, this is the stuff of my grandfather used to walk on. To hear the full series, just search Empire wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我也有一个。你知道，在拉合尔抓了一把泥土带了回来。因为我想，你知道的，这就是我祖父曾经走过的那片土地。要收听完整系列，只需在任何获取播客的地方搜索《帝国》。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。